uh
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by crosstalk.com
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool
threads it's the tits pajamas
some of the voter id laws that we have
seen some situations where
it is harder for minorities to vote in
this country instead of trying to appeal
to diverse voters you just rather try
and block their votes this is nothing
but punitive
designed to keep people from voting we
see about
five people in this entire group of
people that are wearing masks and
actually this is a violation of
smu protocols all of you are in
violation
so
oh
that is disgusting nice i was expecting
something else but because of our
boycott of coke we can't have any topo
chico so i have something that tastes
like
cherry syrup uh put into old pond water
not bad thank you uh whoever served that
to me uh really glad we have a lot going
on today tomorrow we have to change my
mind
uh it's a rough start to the because
apparently we've been banned from
shopify no reason given just your yeah
i don't know but but crowdershop.com is
still up we've had to sort of jerry
reagan i'll update you tomorrow
but today we are going to be live fact
the closing arguments oh uh for the
chavan trial so let's go right now and
see the judge is not wearing his turtle
mask
no what is he talking about he's aiding
the commission of this crime
the elements of the crime of murder in
the second degree oh okay
felony so on the last day of the trial
he's giving more instructions
well i mean this is before deliberately
it's like after putting your bed that
turns into a bookcase together and i'm
like let me check out the swedish
instructions smorgy
oh well it's useless now um we
uh have a great show we have uh gerald a
here how are you i'm well how are you
you know the answer never well how are
you quarterback garrett i'm doing good
so far yeah well you know what
your people were set back a little bit a
little bit at that jake paul
uh we've been asking on the show by the
way ben asking you just uh listen
lost to jake paul yeah in unceremonial
uh unceremonial unceremonious
ceremonious unceremonious fashion thank
you
but uh we have a lot to talk about and
then dave landau landow davis here are
you
ahoy i'm good how about you you know
people missed you when you were gone
i had a lot of fans come out though and
they were awesome they brought me candy
yeah and cigars someone brought you a
fake cuban for me thank you
that's how i know you love me it could
be real it was florida no the guy who
gave it to me he was a white guy clearly
in brown face and he's like i'm a fake
cuban
this is a fake cuban you don't even look
like you and you look dominican
really damn it they all wear tommy
behind wouldn't trust him his double
corona so look
before we go on here to the trial uh we
have a lot to get to as far as maxine
waters the cities have been burning
uh obviously across the country uh we
want to set some context here as to
the the this is one of the tone the
tenor right yeah remember rodney king
you had oj yeah
this is kind of a reverse oj in this
case actually austin said that it's a
bit of a reverse oj and that everyone is
terrified that if they don't convict
this guy
of guilty they're going to be yeah right
right like if they convict them guilty
there might be riots
um but first before we get to any of
that we do have ben askren olympian
multiple time world champion lost to
jake paul he'll be on a little bit later
however this was a fight where he was
fighting jake paul on pay-per-view
yeah and i look i've heard of people
being out of touch
with the youth culture and or urban
culture
yeah but all it was was humping and
gyrating
and i can't even show you the worst of
it so we'll talk with
with ben askren about it but i think we
have a montage to give you a general
idea it was like 90 percent this and 10
versus
fighting during the fight it was there
were no
right before they were very very far i
thought what an
odd fighting style that would be the
booty
for 30 minutes and then so weedy and
then something doggy
and then justin bieber ironically earned
the respect of all americans and being
the least defensive part of that podcast
here's a montage just so you have a
little idea and we're trying to keep it
family friendly
those pants didn't stay on yeah she took
her pants off afterwards
and that jacket came up
and that was with the jacket on yeah by
the way she could totally rachel
dolezalling us i have no idea
when she was yelling the n-word i'm like
i don't think i feel comfortable with
this
no it's like when tech takashi six nine
says it you're like you don't get to do
you don't get to do this
i am not look i'm not if you have kids
here i'm not exaggerating this lady
comes out in a mesh body suit and we're
gonna fact check the
trial here look his thing is he doesn't
have i can't recognize him without the
turtle shell
no she comes out wearing a mesh bodysuit
i'm not even talking about
victoria's secret frederick of hollywood
i'm talking about like you know you pull
off
the side of the road and it's what used
to be a warehouse that says you know
like mr bindi's naughty treats
she's wearing this she does the twerk
there's a guy a
black gentleman person of color colored
people whatever you say uh and his
catchphrase is [ __ ] he just keeps
yelling that into the microphone so
she's twerking
on his groin he's going [ __ ] then she
stands up
turns to the camera grabs her butt
cheeks with her fingers
and spreads them like a rectal exam i
just wonder look and i know
i know everyone has said this from every
generation but can we at least
acknowledge like you know elvis's hips
i wanna hold your hand like we don't
know what they're saying even back to
salt and pepper like push it good too
bust a nut and then pulling your butt
cheeks apart
how are you gonna give your kids can
give your kids a curfew like i told you
eight o'clock like hey mom is this not
you spreading your butt cheeks on live
television
yeah i have more evidence actually well
in fairness though elvis did
spread his butt cheeks wide open for
jailhouse rock
there was a whole shower scene they
didn't show it's the part that
i never loved to tell you about but i
think he fed well because he does
jiu-jitsu man
yeah it's empowering that's what you're
missing it's empowering it's empowering
yeah they're gonna be the next one
what made you think that you could do
that i don't know you told me to play
with your genitals without asking and uh
i took it at face value can you imagine
getting that dancing break
you're after you've been working your
whole life you're like all right we're
just gonna all do this in unison and
you're like
so you want me to what you want me to
fornicate the stage
that's right what's she singing about
he's thinking about playing with her and
what's he saying about boston nuts
oh hmm is there an age restriction is
there an age restriction on this paper
view no none at all
also snoop dogg and oscar de la hoya are
going to be high as a kite oscar de la
hoya i followed his olympic career
attitude
it's just like he's sitting there and he
was so high and so drunk
he's going go baby go to the ussr baby
the guy was a fighter who was on a navy
ship the uss
fa so he had no point of view ussr baby
ussr baby
oh my god so uh by the way you can
follow me on instagram
louder with crowders on instagram this
is a live show uh monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern that's the
and the best thing you can do is comment
we're going to have some questions here
for you today
um let me ask you this where do you
think it's going to be the crappiest as
far as the riots this week
and do you think that there's any
scenario where we don't get riots
if they if they decide first degree
murder maybe yeah
yeah but this is an exception to the
rules so let's have cocktails
yeah i always hated dr scholl's anyway
yeah i'm gonna take portland i know that
wasn't a question for me to answer but
i'm gonna answer anyway i'm gonna take
portland they've been warming up for a
while yeah yes they've tried to stay in
shape for rioting you can't just go out
and ride it right
also the average temperature of portland
has increased by
1.4 degrees ah not carbon monoxide well
technically
it's burning that's due to all the fires
due to all the arson
they want to keep it warm so they're
still giving the instructions here
um and you guys can let us know what the
hashtag is trending uh as far as the uh
the defense we're gonna be live fact
checking we have fact checkers here but
before this
i wanted to talk about something brian
stelter was cornered by one of the
project veritas guys
and i caught something but it's not what
you think
okay a lot of people it's not like this
is huge scandal but something that that
i think i think is a bigger scandal here
you go see if you spot it first here's
the clip from project veritas with brian
super straight stilter do you think it's
gonna be just like a lot of like fear
like climate yeah for yourselves for
yourselves does fear sell
does charlie chester still employed at
cnn i feel really bad for you
is charlie chester still employed
why do you feel bad for me we're
journalists okay why do you feel bad for
me
are you a journalist are you able to
record anything that's not directly
handled or i want
i report whatever i want yes are you
crying no
i'm he's crying here's the thing why is
no one else talking about the fact that
brian stelter
carries a purse look that is a purse
some people were trying to that is
absolutely that's a purse it's a man bag
it's a european man uh
you got to keep your cpap
need the energy to pay out all this
nuisance money so this is absolutely a
person yes it's absolutely a person some
people are trying to argue
no look so i we are going to conduct uh
this is really not so much an experiment
but a showcase for you
okay because i stand by this so now it's
time for uh bringing out even brendan
purse test murst test straight
yes all right even brendan is here so
even brendan let's
start with the uh briefcase okay so this
is the briefcase people are trying to
say well he's carrying a briefcase
you cannot put that in your elbow you
know like a like a lady like a [ __ ]
yeah it doesn't work it doesn't work you
do not carry a briefcase and you're
first off no straight man carries
anything in the crooks of their album
nobody not even straight women
no just gay men do that uh
turn to your side here let's see yeah
and can you bring up the picture again
of brian stelter there look look at the
way he's holding it
very comfortably that's not but let's do
it also with a gym bag because i want to
go through all these or some people are
saying well it could be any of the above
it could be a gym bag that also is not
true
uh but yeah use the actual strap here
with the gym bag because it's a strap
that he has he's not using handles
put that in the crux of your elbow okay
now i think that i think they said he
was carrying jim's bags
he's carrying jim's bag on his way to
service jim's bag
uh there's so there you go yeah there
you go look
it's is it is it a controlled experiment
not exactly but it's enough
brian stelter nuisance money carries a
purse thank you even brendan this has
been
first test murst test straight
up he should wear a cloth mask because
he does look like he's in the hospital
but he really does
yes sir are you about to pass up no he
looks like if tom hanks
was just really dedicated in
philadelphia to gaining weight oh yes
do you know aids will give you 70 extra
pounds oh wow
wow that's what's in the bag all his
medication
all right uh okay so look they're not
talking yet about the uh
about the trial they're not doing their
closing arguments so let's start with
this let's set the stage a little bit
here
last night or two nights ago was this
weekend 60 minutes
beacon of news obviously after truth
speaking of true news
authoritative yeah after we saw what
happened with desantis
um they were you know basically when
they did that they didn't realize they
were spreading their cheeks on live
television
this is gonna hurt uh they aired a
documentary right now on
far-right oath keepers so this is what
the left wants you to focus on
here you go just to set up this context
our guys are very experienced
we have active duty law enforcement in
our organization
that are helping to train us we can
blend in with our law enforcement
in fact in a lot of cases our training
is much more advanced because of our
military backgrounds there's nothing i
love more than my ar-15 and my chainsaw
and i don't know which one i like more
jim arroyo invited us for ourselves
the crowd mostly retirees meet twice a
month
how warm that is to talk about how to
survive disasters like forest fires
these things are great attacks on the
power grid and civil war
so that's why we talk about civil unrest
civil war
it's not a joke this can happen and we
need to be ready for
i don't think they know but they just
inadvertently made the oath keepers seem
entirely reasonable
it seems like my dad's friends forest
fires well those have happened
california
disasters well we've had hurricane
harvey had disasters civil unrest two
billion dollars in damages thousands of
arrests it's like ah so it sounds to me
like they're just saying oh you know
what maybe keep your crap together
uh but they want you to fear the
right-wing militia right they want you
to fear the right-wing extremists
meanwhile
this weekend portland has been burning
down
here's just just a brief montage
mostly peaceful
the building's mostly not on fire
i would say it's mostly not peaceful
i hate you all
i just like how do you let them get that
much lineage
i know i know that's not a word but just
you know i mean just like
put a push bumper on your cop car
something do something at that but you
know what they're gonna do
they're gonna burn stuff down and here's
something else
i want to be clear about something the
back the blue
look i think that conservatives need to
acknowledge we've been talking about
this and sometimes people get mad
when you say look not all police
officers are corruption-free we know
this right
particularly when you look at their
support and they're unwilling to address
the actual extremists who are burning
towns down so this weekend there's a guy
named larry mcfarland okay
he fired his shotgun into the sky oh he
took out a shotgun pointed at the crowd
of people presidents
fired it into the sky yeah joe biden's
advice except it was supposed to be on
your porch
oh yeah right and then your dog fights
like that gunshot wound
and then you pull up the stairs and
shoot your pants
simultaneously and then jill turns on
the microwave and you forget where you
are for a few seconds
that plate right here because it's just
my hair ain't going to look right
and then the media referred to the
riders as anti-police protesters
in that story he was arrested charged
with unlawful use
of a weapon here's something else too
really quickly let me see what they're
talking about scene and then i want to
get to maxine waters is this their
closing argument
looks like he's the court yeah come on
that's not a very good one members of
the jury
his name is robert paulsen was george
perry floyd jr and he was born on
october 14
1973 saint in fayetteville north
carolina
to his parents george floyd senior
and larcenia jones floyd so you can have
tlc
come out say my name well two of the
three of them
yeah you met george floyd's brother
filonas and you heard all about [ __ ]
floyd
she was george floyd's mom she was the
mom of the house she was the mom
of the neighborhood i don't want no
scrubbing and you heard
about the special don't get no love from
me no hanging out the passenger side of
his best friend's ride
really quickly let me just show you
something real before we go to this
because right now he's just setting it
up
yeah if you want to talk about violence
in the streets and i'm telling you
everyone be ready be ready to protect
your family i'm not talking about going
out and waging any violence yourself but
be ready to protect your house and home
because maxine waters and the left they
have been actually actively encouraging
violence i don't mean in veiled terms
yeah i mean in blatant terms this
happened this week in maxine waters
in minnesota talking about what
protesters should do this is what you
need to be ready for they're trying to
intimidate the jury uh this is
justice clipsy i am very hopeful
and i hope that we're going to get
a verdict that is a guilty guilty guilty
and if we don't we we cannot go away and
not just manslaughter right i mean oh no
not manchester united no no no this is
this is guilty
for murder i don't know whether it's in
the first degree but as far as i'm
concerned is first degree
what happens if we do not go get what
you just told what should the people do
what's your protesters on the street
dude
i didn't hear you what happens what
should protesters write their local
representatives well
we got to stay on the street uh and
we've got to get
more active we've got to get more
confrontational
we've got to make sure that they they
know that we need business
and by the way only a couple hours later
there was a drive-by shooting in
minnesota
on national guard police here you go
here's a quick clip
well national guard troops providing
security for residents in the area of
penn avenue and broadway
in minneapolis this morning were shot at
at 4 19
a.m gunshots came from a white suv
towards a minnesota national guard in
minneapolis her house is on fire
neighborhood security in that area the
two national guard troops suffered
minor injuries one national guard member
had to go to a hospital for treatment of
lacerations from shattered glass
and final thing i want to show before we
go here to the closing arguments and
then cover it live
this is not the first time look if
donald trump
was kicked off of all big tech platforms
and people tried to say that he incited
violence
maxine waters needs to be federally
charged and impeached
because this is not the first time that
this has happened here's just a few of
her greatest hits
uh clippy and we fight
we fight like hell oh wait sorry i'm
sorry i meant uh
turn on them they're gonna protest
they're gonna uh
absolutely harass them until they
decide that they're going to tell the
president no i can't hang with you
harass them she said go and take trump
out tonight
oh that's nice
he's saying no no sleep you see anybody
from that cabinet in a restaurant
in a department store at a gasoline
station
you get out
that sounds familiar you're not your
kind's not welcome around here
oh yeah and people wonder why gina
carrano compared the saying hey look she
didn't compare being republican to being
a jew in the holocaust she said how did
it start you got they got
their fellow citizens to tell on them
to snitch on them to round them up for
the government that's what she was
talking about now if donald trump gets
in trouble for saying fight like hell
and tell him to protest peacefully keep
in mind too when donald trump said that
that was a group of hundreds of
thousands of people
there had never been a massive violent
right-wing protest it didn't exist
maxine waters
was amidst the city's burning and said
more confrontational tell them they're
not welcome this was after billions of
dollars in damages
and dozens of people killed and hundreds
of officer casualties
maxine waters has seen the violence has
seen the carnage
and has encouraged it and even worse
none of the other democrats
have said anything they've all fallen
silent because they want this jury right
now to convict
they are trying to wherever you line up
what we do have to agree
upon is in this justice system you
cannot have coercion
uh with what's supposed to be an
independent jury okay let's go to these
closing uh closing arguments
a grown man crying out for his mother
a human no he was crying out for his his
uh cracked out girlfriend
mama that's how she was listed in his
cell phone by the way
and in that doesn't mean it's less sad
it just means that he right now
knowingly lied
while he was surrounded in life a lawyer
no what's this world coming to
honestly there was no one there he just
sucks he was surrounded
by strangers strangers
all of them nine minutes and twenty
nights what like every coco
patient this year right without any of
their loved ones not a familiar face to
say
his final words
but he did say them to someone
he said them to someone who he did not
know
by name but he knew him from the uniform
he wore and the badge he wore
hey by the way this is also false
because remember they tried to say that
they worked at the same club together
and that
derrick chavin was out to get him
remember he was racially motivated
because they worked security at the same
club but now they're saying he didn't
know anyone
oh didn't know him he called him officer
which was which is it
george floyd's final words on may 25
2020 were please
i can't breathe okay let's bring that
clip that we have we have a clip i don't
know which clip it is
of him saying that he couldn't breathe
when he was back in
the car i believe that that was uh hold
on a second can someone tell me what's
going
on can someone tell me which clip that
is we said it he said it several times
too
right before going to the ground yeah
clip p clip p he was saying long before
he went to the ground he was saying it
before
he had made it to the ground he was
saying it in the car while getting in
the car clip p floyd
maintained uh or stated that he could
not breathe
while uh in the prone position that is
correct
he stated that before uh ever
being in the prone position as well
correct that is correct several times
correct that is correct at that point
when he stated
that he can't breathe and he's in the
back seat of the car there was no one on
his back right
that's correct sir and do you know
whether at that point there's any
evidence to suggest that there was a
respiratory depressant such as fentanyl
on on board in his system uh
no sir so again just just letting you
know
this false narrative called for his
mother no he didn't called for his
girlfriend who would do drugs with him
and uh his last words were those were
his words leading up
until his request to be put on the
ground that matters that changes context
on that day no courage was required
all that was required was a little
compassion
he gonna cry none was shown sorry i'll
take it here
on that day don't do that dave i just
see he looks like he's gonna cry
and he's got a lawyer you know he
doesn't cry this was
a call about a counterfeit twenty dollar
bill
no it wasn't it wasn't a call about a
twenty dollar counterfeit bill
it was a call because he gave a 20 uh
dollar counterfeit bill
it was a kid at the shop who could see
that he was likely high out of his mind
knew it was a counterfeit 20
bill was intimidated and kindly
approached george floyd
two times to either give him back the
pack of cigarettes
or the 20. in which scenario george
floyd bullied the kid
and brushed him off and so the kid who
felt guilty for calling the cops not
wanting to lose
an hour of his pay said look this guy is
giving out
counterfeit 20 bills that's what
happened that's what happened
it wasn't just a counterfeit 20. he was
bullying a kid and he had several
opportunities to make it right
he continued to push him down to grind
into him i do agree with you there and
the first time that they went in with a
counter for 20 his friend
if it was about a counter for 20 the
cops would have been called then right
yeah it wasn't that at that point the
kid is losing 40 of his pay
it's not yeah this assault
when he was unable to speak the
defendant continued
when he was unable to breathe the
defendant continued beyond the point
that he had a pulse
beyond the point that he had a pulse the
defendant continued
this assault nine minutes
and 29 seconds when the ambulance
arrived
the ambulance was here
and the defendant continued he stayed on
top of him he would not get up
he would not let up he stayed on him
grinding into him continuing to twist
his feet now he's talking about the
fight
down he had no pulse
no that's not true he stayed on him
restraining him until
he could hand him over to the paramedics
yeah that's what you do
paramedics are not trained to restrain
somebody who's that large
and has a history of violence yeah what
are you supposed to do wait like oh
paramedics are here all right get up
then you end up like the scenario with
the female cop yelling taser taser taste
the guys go no this is a weak female who
has no business being on the force
here's my chance for a break
what do you think they're gonna do with
paramedics who have no training in
subduing an assailant
finally the defendant got up that woman
has a nice briefcase
yes mr floyd onto that gurney and you
saw
stelter's eyeing it yeah the way he was
not
your case his head
is she a stenographer to prevent it from
falling to the ground he was completely
limp
the defendant had to know that he was
there
he was on top of him and he was on top
of him on top of him
sometimes you ask for the truth
sometimes rather the officer be beneath
him
yeah but what is where's an officer
supposed to be when waiting for
paramedics
the officer was like a missionary
ready to get it
the medical examiner
would find the cause of george floyd's
death
to be a cardiopulmonary arrest
complicating law enforcement subdual
restraint and neck compression
what you saw the defendant and the other
officers doing to george floyd
caused his death
the medical examiner ruled
the death again we've been really clear
about this i don't even have this in
front of me for people who haven't been
following this and you don't know if
you're just tuning into this for the
first time
they have to rule it something as far as
a cause of death homicide it's not a
criminal term
it means that it was a death that
involved someone else there
yeah that doesn't mean homicide in the
way that you know it to be and they
actually had the witnesses testify and
they were very clear about that
so they know right now they're throwing
this out so people go oh homicide
i watch csi miami yeah i know what i'm
talking about
it's murder no homicide means he died in
the presence of someone else
even if it was a drug overdose and the
officer had him in the back of the car
that's a homicide yeah that's why i said
don't say it yeah and a second ago and
then
but he said it doing something wasn't
hearing you like this
remember in jury selection i mean we
talked about
bias and we talked there's the shell
biases and preconceived notions behind
do they show it again
well the attorney the other
crime this is like where's waldo but
with the dumb shell mask
you have to set aside because that's
just not the way we think of police
officers
are you hiding in a pond with box
turtles that makes it hard to find you
although
we believe the police are going to
respond to our call for help
i poured chemicals on myself and i'm not
a mutant
i've just done a lot of damage to my
body this runs deep it's difficult to
set this aside i want you to consider
that even after with the bystanders
after they saw what they saw after they
saw this shocking display
of abuse of police power and a man
murdered in front of them
genevieve hansen she called the police
donald williams he saw this you heard
him he testified
he called the police a nine-year-old
judea what did she suggest
we need to call the police on the police
that's our expectation even after seeing
this even after witnessing this our
expectation
is that the police are going to help
well hold on a second isn't that
predicated on the fact that the police
are going to help
victims not the criminals
so in this case let's be clear victim
was a kid who had two counterfeit 20s
who called the cops just wanted it to be
and then he had an unruly super super
high
violent george floyd just like when we
talk about jacob blake to protect us
to protect the woman who was sexually
assaulted who called the cops because he
violated a restraining order we've lost
this is this is how you end up with a
dirty harry or
charles bronson you end up with an area
where the police right they've had their
teeth taken out they've been defunded
and you end up where the society says we
want a cop who does things his own way
because you see skyrocketing crime like
we're seeing right now
oh so it's the police job it's the
police's job to take care of the
assailant before the victim
and this is how they change it it's no
look george floyd had a long rap sheet
a long rap sheet of being violent he had
been arrested before multiple times he
had spent time in prison
he was committing a crime he bullied a
kid and then at that point
they were very nice with him initially
telling him to get in the car freaking
out
and now they have to deal with an
assailant it didn't they weren't called
because george floyd was the victim now
if they'd have come in
and kneeled on the kid and roughed him
up that would be different
that's not what happened in this
scenario that's not what happened with
jacob blake that's not what happened i
mean you can go down the list
it's never what happens almost all of
these scenarios
involve officers dealing with the
committer
of crime and then it gets complicated we
need to keep that in mind
because you doesn't mean that anyone
deserves to die just to be clear george
floyd did not deserve to die
okay jacob blake i would argue at that
point look you're reaching for a knife
kind of dude deserve to die at that
point however any time you're committing
a crime and you actively and violently
resist arrest
you are consciously forfeiting your
right to live
because you now understand that the odds
of a complication go up
yeah and that's something we need to be
teaching everybody watching
is if you commit a crime and you
actively resist arrest which is now
you're now committing another crime
usually a violent crime right if you're
resisting arrest you forfeit your right
to live in the sense that you have to
accept the ramifications of those
actions
it shouldn't happen but accidents happen
yeah
and if you disagree with that you're
saying that the officer doesn't have a
right to go home to their family that
night exactly
exactly that's what you're telling them
all right let's go back to this uh this
professional liar who staffed the
training center
and they told you
we don't train this
that's not true that's a lie that's not
true can someone bring that up we have
the we have the flyer
i don't know if we have the video too um
there it is yep there you go there's a
flashlight train technique maximal
restraint technique was used over 200
times
yep i think what was it the year before
yep so
all of the public all of the human
beings matter of fact we have clip r use
of force expert barry broad
uh brought up that he was justified in
his restraint again because this is you
can find it it's not even something
that's like one of those hidden
techniques like seven minutes ago
like oh this is the technique that i
don't teach because it's too dangerous
they pass it out you never see it the
camera can't register it
it involves cake and me in the bathroom
i'll be back a tank and pop you ever
seen tub girl it's tub
one boy one big cup of ice cream
clip r this is also confirmation of what
we're talking about now
based upon uh your training and
experience and your expertise and the
use
of force matters what are your 11 herbs
and spices provided to you
have you formed opinions in this
particular case
to a reasonable reasonable degree of
professional certainty
i have and can you just briefly overview
your opinions in this particular case
i felt that derek chauvin was justified
and was acting with objective
reasonableness
following minneapolis police department
policy
and current standards of law enforcement
and his interactions with mr floyd so
it's easy to sit and judge
in an office on an officer's conduct
it's
more of a challenge to again put
yourself in the officer's shoes to try
to make an evaluation
through what they're feeling what
they're sensing the fear they have
and then make a determination also
really quick you guys can bring it up
this restraint was used what 200
something times since 2016 or 2019.
so it's been used hundreds of times uh
to act as though this is an outlier it's
not
it's not it's how they train police it's
been used hundreds of times
just to be clear if you have a problem
with it then your problem is with the
police department it's with
bad police training and i have that
problem too yeah it's not with derrick
shotgun all right let's continue and
bring up that source when you can
are people is there a hashtag right now
going out with this thing does anyone
know i would
imagine people are still watching it on
twitter and instagram
assault i'm going to discuss the law
with you
in a bit here and and explain
the court's already provided you some
instructions on second-degree murder and
you know
under the laws of this 237 times 37
times certain level of us rendered 44
people unconscious they claim
and a person dies as a result of your
assault
you're guilty of murder
it's as simple as that and what the
defendant did here
was a straight up felony assault this
was not policing
it was unnecessary it was gratuitous
it was disproportionate and he did it
on purpose
on purpose how do you know that he's
pushing for first degree murder this is
la
this is laying the trap right now where
if people and any reasonable person goes
well look come on
this wasn't on purpose this wasn't
premeditated murder
they now have this backrest they now
have this this backdrop of
oh but wait a second he did it on
purpose so anything other than
first-degree murder
riot yeah that's the problem is is not
that people have different opinions it's
the irresponsibility
of people saying either it's first
degree murder or the system is broken
and everything is racist
right right well i don't even think
first degree is charged in this i think
it's just
it was reduced yeah it's been reduced
that's the problem is he's going for
something that he actually can't be
convicted of
yeah and that's the problem with the
woman wha what's her name we just saw
uh taser taste maxine waters mexican
waters thank you that's the problem as
well is she stirring people up knowing
that the end result is not going to be
that yeah just like the end result of
her wig sometimes the parts on the left
are the right
easy bill o'reilly she puts it on
backwards sometimes in the back
just looking out for the folks all i'm
trying to say keep it pithy
all right james brown wait wait wait
wait let's go back to this guy
well this all started over a call of an
alleged counterfeit
twenty dollar not alleged not an actual
one
i didn't realize that lawyers are i
guess during closing arguments they're
allowed to just
lie completely without rejection on
purpose alleged
this is felony assault yeah this is just
that like this would have never been
allowed in the questioning call out for
his mom
no oh yeah that's where they get the
closing arguments there's all you know
lies
in a steve harvey suit everything that
you remember i was gonna say a little
bit more of a don
cherry it's something there yeah in this
courtroom you can't go out of bounds
uh this is just made by fat farm do you
like it can i pull it off
okay anyway so he's on the ground
you better be better
the kind of ego based pride
that the defendant was not going to be
told what to do he was nervous
he's bystanders tell him what to do he
didn't get told what to do put me on the
ground
okay i'll put you on the ground that's
amazing i guess that's what he's saying
yeah he wasn't going to be told what to
do what do you mean
which instruction the i'll [ __ ] you up
that one than the bystanders
i mean i just like like the accent so no
police are not supposed to acquiesce to
bicycles that's not ego
i don't i don't do right it'd be like me
right now going well i guess you know
instead of this i'm gonna do a no spin
zone and go to o'reilly because people
are like oh someone says i want you to
do bill o'reilly
no he sucks and i don't want him to
touch me
and he will again again yeah yes
he's a very handsy man who writes books
about god
oh yeah that's an assassinating jesus
yeah he does yeah jfk should write his
own killing my career
yes how to do dressed uh for court like
you also can tell that he wrote them at
the same time with his ghost writer
because the thief on the cross was lee
harvey oswald
that was a weird stopover in the airport
but the defendant the defendant was
trying to win he wasn't going to be told
what to do
he wasn't going to take a challenge to
his authority
he was trying to win and george floyd
paid for it with his time i mean like i
guess a wayne is an arrest like
regardless of anything i've said though
that's not what happened
like it could be or he could be
responsible for his death i've always
said that and i stand by that but he
wasn't trying to win
anything no that was just if if he was
trying to like
he would just let him go if it was a
contest like he was trying to win
anything it would be like all right guys
just
you shouldn't be able to lie to jurors
like that like what evidence do you have
that he was trying to win did he smirk
like while the crowd was like haha look
he's staying down as a matter of fact
anything
he turned over to his female partner who
was not there and she said
there's one thing i want you to do for
me he said what she said come here he
said what she said come here
and then he heard a bell gong
this all happened i would uh refer you
to the star that's another
jury's like this is a lie he's like well
it's closing statement so yeah i'll say
what i want
just remember doesn't this guy look like
a character actor playing a lawyer
yeah like where are the ghostbusters i
had them committed
he looks like yeah he'd be prosecuting
the the ghostbusters are a menace to
this
and then something comes in and like he
learns his lesson like
maybe he falls into a cake oh
the sclera brothers oh no
all right hold on i need to
back to the car he's with his friends
and there's a tap at the window
he looks to his left and a start
this is what he sees no no no no no
no no no no no no no someone bring up
that clip let's bring up that clip he
did not just
walk up with his gun that was after he
refused to show his hands you know what
before we bring that clip
let's bring up the clip of him doing
this before just so you know
george floyd has a long and storied
history of uh resisting and by the way
you're already resisting arrest if you
don't show your hands yeah so this is
the previous clip
of george floyd being arrested while we
find this one that is not how that
started
and that matters clip
look see there's no gun right now he's
not showing his hands
right there boom gun glove compartment
cops have been shot for less
hands are up put him up on the dash put
them on the desk
he's putting them below again i'm not
going to shoot you put your hands
on the dash i'm not going to shoot your
hands
on the dash the last time i'm going to
tell you that it's simple
isn't this a different clip though you
know this is this is an arrest before
and then we're gonna bring up the arrest
they want you to think that the cop
walked up with a gun yeah no that's not
how it happened
this is a guy whose mo is actively
resisting arrest by not showing his
hands and keep in mind he's a violent
serial
felon
all right that's enough of that clip and
let me know when we have the actual clip
of the arrest uh we should have it from
our uh from our previous show maps
they want you to it yeah let's bring
back up cena they want you to think that
the guy
walked out like was a fir like it was
golden eye tapping first person shooter
tapping with his gun
hey tap tap oh gosh that startled me can
you open the window sir
no the cop walked up and told him i am
not going to shoot you
put your hands on the dash or at that
point i think since it was the driver's
side
hands on the wheel that is so misleading
there you have it all right here's the
actual clip
see no gun in his hand let me see your
hands stay in the car let me see
your other hand i'm sorry let me see
your other hand please
both hands now he brings out the gun
when he can't see the other hand which
could be reaching
yeah what did we do put your hand up
there
still not complying and then he says i'm
not going to shoot you i'm not going to
shoot you
which i almost think police officers
shouldn't say right you should leave
that on
it should be yes not going to shoot you
but maybe if you will see if you have a
gun and you pull it on me
if you try to kill me i will shoot you
yeah i'm already thinking about it
i think police policy should be you aim
the gun at them and you say don't worry
the safety's off
oh [ __ ] that should be the policy just
to put the fear of god in them a little
bit
all right let's go back to this liar
they take him over to the car
george floyd is a big guy right
you can see here i mean he's almost as
big as officer lane
he's bigger yeah he's a big person
the back of the squad car is not
oh come on that's what they wanted
it's a full-size suv it's not even a
crossover it's the he got out of an suv
it's the new explorer it's enormous it
just makes common sense
he's 223 pounds and even though
aren't there other cars there that are
smaller like didn't they pick the big
one
oh my gosh get out of a smaller car all
right i want to hear him justify now
that he
required being on the ground where was
far more comfortable in the back of a
full-size expedition
he just wasn't able to bring himself to
do it
what that's like that's like a limo
pulling up for you
and instead be like no no just roll that
dumpster over
and i'm gonna ride in that here's the
excuse that he just gave
he he just couldn't bring himself to do
it so you can just not get in a cop car
when you're under arrest i'm sorry
officer i just can't bring myself to do
it i can't
no look at how tiny that thing is it
looks like ryan reynolds buried alive
film
yes the ability to get in the car he's
explaining himself
repeatedly and you can't see out of his
mind and officer tao
start coming into the scene right
and we'll we'll look at him by the way
explaining himself saying he can't
breathe right now there just does it is
that explaining himself he's saying he
can't breathe
because again that would imply that
there are breathing complications that
have nothing to do
with shoving with shock not saying it
helped
saying he was already using it so you
can't trust everything that came out of
george floyd's mouth was a lie in that
altercation just to be clear and
everything this lawyer has said
ever and i'm not saying it's incorrect
it is a
lie george floyd said i didn't do
nothing yes you did said i'm not that
kind of guy
yes you are my mom just died no she
didn't i can't breathe
yes you can i didn't do any drugs yes
you did okay
this guy just said called out for his
mother no he didn't called out for his
girlfriend
he just said couldn't fit in the back
it's very small nope that's not true
he said this is how the officer
approached him showed a picture of a gun
that's not true this is not how the
police force is trained to restrain
people that's not true
everything george floyd said was a lie
everything this lawyer has said thus far
is a lie and i'm not saying that they
don't have a case
but he's not going with the case because
the witnesses never really it never
really went that well for the
prosecution including
their own witnesses but they pulled him
out of a small car does nobody see this
it's a terrible defense horrible we
pulled him out of a tiny clown car
there's room for many people in there we
all know it's magic they could fit
shaquille o'neal in the back of that
police of course come on
that's not even a good ugh he just
couldn't bring himself to do it
still right there on the surface
unbelievable
emotion i don't doubt that he had issues
and stuff
divorced oh yeah yeah completely bad
it's terribly sad mental illness
mental health issues like
drug and alcohol abuse being locked
inside for a year
hopes being taken away from you running
out of options resist
but just not be able to bring themselves
to comply
wait what at that moment at that time
that's called resistance that's not
an excuse there is no new definition of
resisting arrest that you can come up
with
he just couldn't bring himself to comply
remember
took the stand he testified he testified
i guess that's the defense yeah that's
that's you know listen i committed a
crime and they wanted to arrest me but i
couldn't bring myself
to allow myself to be arrested myself i
had a divorce
i'm sorry you're free to go is that a
grown-up thing to do
we didn't know that i mean thanks for
telling us i do wish during one of my
arrests i could have been like uh my
parents are divorced they'd be like no
they're not i'd be like yeah but you
know spiritually they are
they don't get along they're gonna go
dead to each other they should ask every
single perp dave can you bring yourself
to get in the back of this full-size suv
you could be like it's not roomy enough
they're like you're you're come on
you're not come on
look at you you can get in there you can
get in the gloves
you'll get in there and your legs will
be dangling like the oscar mayer
commercial
and a reasonable officer in the
defendant's place with all his training
and all his experience
including that 40-hour crisis
intervention course and a subsequent
refresher course
should have known that and should have
recognized it floyd was trying to get
into the car he was trying to work up
the courage he said he'd count to three
but he just couldn't do it i
care well you it's not about working up
the courage to be arrested
his argument here should be his argument
here should be the cop should have
completely disregarded george floyd's
feeling
and shoved him in the back of that car
and kept him there until he was drawing
lines in the wall like the count of
monte cristo
he should have been edmond dun test in
the back of that car that's what they
should be saying but right now they're
making the case against themselves
saying
he couldn't get in the back of the car
okay so he had to go on the ground he
shouldn't be on the ground so you're
saying he should just go free when he
commits a crime
this is a horrible argument and that's
largely been my point the whole time is
put him in the back
no matter what get him out of there i
believe he would still be alive that's
the only reason why this guy may be
you know he may be partially responsible
but
that's a large part is you can't like
you have to get them in there you have
to get them out of there
that's just my opinion but i think i'm
right seeing as he's dead
right well well you know what tomato
tomato let's uh turn this up so we can
hear them
so they don't listen they just shut up
yeah
they shut them and then they do listen
and take him out
and that's the problem he should have
been stuffed in that car
and kept in that car with the child lock
on look
this is my question this is your
question ultimately to the left and it's
the same question with the rioters and
the maxine waters it's like okay
all right committed a crime what do we
do
well you arrest him we need better
training okay tries to de-escalate
george floyd doesn't show his hands what
do you do
okay you bring him back then you bring
him back and now he doesn't want to get
in the car
what do you do well he they wouldn't
listen to him okay so what do you do
well then you don't put him in the car
okay so he requests to go on the ground
what do you do well then you restrain
then he says he doesn't want to be
restrained
what do you do at a certain point you've
got to start adulting sweetheart
at a certain point you either accept
that the police have the authority to
arrest people
or they don't this guy seems to be
implying that you can't do anything a
criminal doesn't like
basically same thing with maxine waters
okay if it's uh not guilty what do you
do
we riot okay if it's manslaughter what
do you do we riot
if it's second degree what do you do we
riot if it's tuesday
yeah we're right oh you're getting it
basically
there's a mean pair of dunks in that
window what we riot
well all right here they're gonna show
this clip again
of god
this is the result of him refusing to
get in the car which you just said was a
problem they didn't listen to him
they should not have listened to him
they should have shoved him
in the car period all right
there four officers
and what did george floyd say once they
pulled him out of the car
i request you thank you
now a reasonable officer in the
defendant's position at that time should
have
recognized and understood he wasn't
trying to escape
he wasn't trying to punch him by the way
he kicked them clip
in clip in he actively kicked a cop
uh kicked his leg
and could you describe that kick and how
that might be
interpreted by a reasonable police
officer yes so the
officers were still attempting to
control mr floyd at the time
and um as they were trying to place him
down
in the prom position i believe one of
the officers was attempting to
control his legs and mr floyd uh kicked
their arms away in an attempt to try to
possibly um break free from
from the officer's uh grasp
oh but then after that he said he said
thank you after he kicked them and they
got him down on the ground by request he
said thank you by the way little known
fact they can't arrest you if you say
pretty please
true was that uh cedric the
entertainer's brother cedric the
explainer
it was sedwick said yeah
don't count your tips in public see
tweak all right hold on let me we gotta
listen
hold that thought i'm sure it's
hilarious but right now i'm angry at
this don
cherry suited piece of [ __ ]
to expand and take in air so they can
breathe
that is a step that protects against the
known danger
of positional asphyxia
and they have him there he's right there
so then what happens after
they take him incredibly out of the
recovery position
and prone him on the ground
for what the prone position is a
transitory position
it's a position you use to secure
someone in handcuffs
and when you're done with that you
immediately roll it it's also a position
they use when people have covid to
assist with their breathing
time out it it is a transitional
position to wear
what is the ultimate goal handcuffs they
already had them in handcuffs the next
thing roll them put them on his feet put
him in the car
they just tried that right what would
you like them to transition to they have
to wait for the parents they were
waiting for people because this guy was
high out of his mind
did you call out like zack morris yes i
did
i'm sorry it just pisses me off no i
tried it when i get angry i
quote saved by the bill by the way also
a little known fact that officers if you
just want to get a mass arrest just
walk into uh the north ward in st louis
and yellow all the other oxen free
[ __ ] oh man you got me you got me
honor system man i was hiding the
driver's system there's this idea that
he should have been
and i can i can see it honestly but like
you sit him down you calm him down that
sort of thing i get
i get that's the idea and i think that
that there is they did though they
before they put him in the car they had
him
up against the wall saying calm down
you're right that's where they asked him
are you on something
no he had minutes he had minutes before
they even tried to put him in the car
yeah and then he had minutes where they
tried to put him but
he had to go on the ground after they
kicked my and my goal i don't know how i
guess and i'm not
i don't know how long it has to be does
it need to be i don't i don't either
that's my point
i'm asking questions no no i know but
i'm saying he did have minutes where he
was up against the wall and said hey man
hey man calm down are you on anything
oh what what's going on do you have any
issues right they were asking him that
up against the wrong
on the window and then he said i'll roll
down the window calm down
i don't know again we can all get to the
point of where he's on the ground but
that's by request
up until that point i don't think they
could have been more empathetic that's
where i differ with a lot of people i
really can't think
of a more empathetic police officer than
saying hey man are you on anything
what's going on all right we're going to
get you in the back of this car okay hey
no
look i'm gonna stay with you i'm gonna
put the air conditioning on i'm gonna
open the window
get in the car i don't expect that yeah
i don't know what they were supposed to
do and if he couldn't bring himself to
get in the car the first time
your lawyer you just said this could you
think magically the second time he's
going to
what's the end result he's not in the
car the problem is
if if you ask him what are you on you're
not going to get an answer because it's
then a further charge
so there has to be some and i i mean i
hate to say that there has to be
something that said like this is
to save your life we need to know if
you're on something so we can take you
out of restraints
whatever it is not saying that they need
to do that right i'm just saying
that would be something that would ha i
don't it's too hard to do well
there's no realistic way to do it
because you're not going to admit to a
crime
right while you're being arrested right
that's just the reason certainly not if
you've committed several violent crimes
like robbing a woman in front of her
kids in your house i mean like this is
not a guy
this is also something you need can you
also agree here too with
george floyd eddie haskelling a little
bit okay the kind of guy
who has who's already stepped over the
line of robbing a woman at gunpoint
scoping out a woman who's alone with her
toddler in the house
robbing her at gunpoint roughing her up
and then when an officer you you know
you're acting like michael clark duncan
yes sir no sir could you leave the light
on sir it's like come on look
look you just you just brushed a kid off
after giving a counterfeit 20
and he really nicely just said man come
on they're gonna take it out of my
they're gonna take it out of my pay
before you arrest me you can have some
of your wife's coins
hey so austin in the edit bay he just he
said we missed this the prosecutor said
believe your eyes what you saw but the
problem is
people aren't seeing the full tape
a perfect example of that is here's a
witness who is saying
that george floyd this is clip i said
never said
i never heard him say i ate too many
drugs and him being presented with
something that he couldn't possibly have
heard
from their smartphone amidst yelling of
how you would f the officer up if you
were in that situation so this is a
perfect example of why you can't just
believe
what you're seeing your angle your
vantage point what you're able to hear
clip by here's a perfect example
did you attempt to understand and hear
copy again from often what
various parties were saying at various
times
yes he heard it he says do you did you
ever hear
mr floyd say i ate too many drugs
no
did he say it though
there it is did you hear that yes i did
did it appear that mr floyd said
i ate too many drugs yes it did
there you go believe what you see in
here okay
this guy doesn't want the truth that's
what's really clear about this he he
wants the opposite of the truth well and
that's what i'm saying i want the truth
as well and if that means he's guilty of
a crime then i want him to go to jail
yeah
i am not here trying to to preach that
we should let chavin go and and nothing
should happen
i just want truth to come out that's it
but that's him telling him that he ate
too many drugs correct
yeah what point did he do that that's
him confessing and letting him around
yeah well i think that that is
definitely something that
should be taken into account yeah it
should be taken into account not against
the other police who i don't think could
even hear you but
my point is but against sheldon i think
so this guy this guy right now is saying
believe your eyes believe what you see
and the point is that was someone who
was there
someone who had reviewed it somebody
said i heard it all i'm saying did you
hear this
no they play it did you hear it now yes
so the point is this guy
is saying believe what you saw on uh on
youtube
believe what you saw on worldstar
believe what you saw in you know on
nbc believe the selectively edited
eclipse just believe what you s what
you've seen
don't believe all of the additional
evidence
don't believe what's been presented
don't believe the
aggregate of everything that has been
presented here he wants people
he wants low information jurists
that's what he is doing right now he's
actively trying to eliminate
the most relevant evidence that could
only come out in court
to say let's go back to when you first
saw the video and you felt really
emotional
that's how you should charge this guy
let me go back to hear what he's saying
now
is that common sense or is that nonsense
and by the way you guys let me know
comment below that's the best thing you
can do is comment i know right now you
can't because it's live we'll be taking
your mug club chat
but as soon as this is uh up on youtube
just comment what you if this is
convincing you if you see this
as subversive as i do i can't believe
what this guy is doing i mean i can
i don't like it that requires a
tolerance
you know what the toxicology report says
in terms of the levels and you know what
the testimony was about that
die of a drug overdose mean overdose
level for fentanyl
overlay h is 3.1 nanograms per
milliliter floyd had 11 nanograms per
milliliter now keep in mind he's trying
to say he had a tolerance
but again beforehand they said george
floyd hadn't committed any crime george
floyd was clean
remember now they're saying he wasn't
who said he wasn't mama his girlfriend
said we've been doing drugs so which is
it had he been clean straightened up and
flied right or
was he with mama crack girlfriend crack
feeding girlfriend who talked about them
doing drugs and he built up a tolerance
so much that he
was willing to pass counterfeit 20 to
get his next hit
this you do have to have one or the
other
because now if you're saying ignore all
the new evidence ignore that mama was
his girlfriend
that he was doing drugs okay well then
we go back to the fact that oh he was
clean
well the mean overdose level friendly
was 3.1 he was 11. okay case closed
no no no actually he was doing so many
drugs
that uh he had such a high tolerance oh
but you just said he was lucid you just
said he was explaining himself
articulately
you just said he was calling out for his
mother so which is it
there is no way to take this
prosecution's closing statement at face
value it doesn't work
because the parts of his statement right
now don't match up with the initial
parts
manslaughter in the second degree the
judge read you
you know what the law says those things
are and the law breaks down
these different charges into things
called elements
first element second element where's
maxine waters called it burn the
[ __ ] no matter
in order for the defendant to be guilty
of those charges i am
a representative person
this is an opinion as he says
i think that george floyd along with a
lot of people are just simply you get
somebody who's a drug addict at the end
of his rope he has no hope he has
nowhere to go he's really not going to
turn around and change to be a better
part of society because
frankly he kind of can't i know that's
hard to believe but he's just at a point
in his life where he's out of options
at this point we've shut down most of
the country where we're now riling up
people who feel like they're useless
they don't have any value they're
completely out of options
and now we're telling them to burn down
cities yeah we're telling them they're
not worthy and we're telling them not
only that
but that they are in fact this man right
and you know what else you know what
people die from
it's not just know what loneliness and
what's made people lonely it takes way
more time off your life
than uh than coveted statistically if
you look at it if you look at the mean
age of dead not saying co it is not
deadly
saying people who are lonely
particularly in their older age they die
much sooner just like people who
actually live in two-story homes
live longer once you get to a certain
age these are basic facts of life
loneliness mental health
issues drug addiction i don't agree with
you they didn't have any other options i
mean you had options look you were
you're someone who you've been open
about that you were an addict and i
think everyone has a choice at some
point and this is george floyd who
chose this right now look there are
several choices there counterfeit 20s
doing drugs hanging around with the same
people committing more crimes there are
people who've had worse stories than
george floyd who've come out of it i
never believe that someone
is completely out of options and
certainly not from what i've read with
george but he opted for that because it
was the easier money
no i think he believed it that's my
point i'm not saying that he was
but i think he believed that right well
who do you why do you think he believes
it because people like maxine waters
tell him that's your only option because
people like joe biden say that's your
only option
white people bad everyone's holding you
down everyone's holding you back they
don't tell you look right now in places
in florida they are paying you
fifty dollars to show up for a job
interview at mcdonald's we can have the
the news team back there fact bring it
up fifty dollars to show up for an
interview wow
because people won't show up right now
they don't wanna work wow they feel
comfortable enough with the government
money that's a big problem that's why
there's a shortage right now
is that true what sign up for a ton of
interviews
i'm getting free [ __ ] but i agree he
thinks he doesn't have options correct
the issue is and i'm speaking from an
attic point of view yes and where that's
a medical problem right drug addiction
is not just a mental problem it is
or a brain issue like choosing right it
is a medical issue right it has to be
treated as such
and it's it's treated as punishment and
i understand that because a lot of it is
a crime but
when you are a drug felon and all that
you know everything that he had
happening to him it is very very hard to
make a transition to think you're not
useless
not everybody's danny trump that being
said that look that being said
there are plenty of people with drug
problems and there are plenty of people
with drug problems
who commit crimes to try and get the
next fix there's a big 100 percent of
the big difference between that and
scoping out a house with a mom who you
know is vulnerable going in with a gang
with guns and putting her at gunpoint
jamming it into her stomach in front of
her kid
that is not i'm out of options that's a
sinister bastard
have you smoked crack hey i love this
from business insider
mcdonald's and flirt is paying people 50
just to show up for a job interview but
it's still not attracting many
applicants
oh wow good enough 50 is not enough
no i don't know no options system no i
would go just for the 50 bucks yeah get
your next score
and then they'd call me and they'd be
like i'm gonna wear mcdonald's i'm not a
loser
i'm kidding and then you'd be like oh
really after only six months these are
your employee benefits those are
competitive
next thing i got a call yeah dave you're
quitting yep yeah
well and they're just they're talking
about cause of death stuff here so i
figure we have just a second i
i think what george floyd did in crime
uh you know robbing that woman
deplorable right
here's the thing drugs make you do
things that you would never otherwise do
they know no but here's this hold on no
let me make my point i have a sister who
went through this i understand that they
will make you do things you should never
ever think that you would do mentally it
puts you in a place
where you're no longer making the
decisions like you normally would and
that's not an excuse
that's a warning don't start using drugs
unless you want to end up in a really
really bad
yes and i've had a lot of responses and
i've had an experience with it too i
mean my dad had a guy who worked who we
tried to help for a long time yeah uh
steal his truck and then
actually found had a pair of had a pair
of razors and some rope i remember that
um and that being said
drugs don't make you premeditatedly
violent
in other words there are a lot of people
who do drugs who try and figure out a
way to do you know petty robbery
something like that
pickpocketing stealing a car typically
speaking
someone who is doing drugs who doesn't
want to hurt someone else but
wants to get more drugs well at least
try those first not
show up with a gang of guys and with
guns scoping out the most vulnerable
among us
uh and jamming a gun in a woman's
stomach that is not something that all
look just like when i say when people
say uh hey you have mental health issues
you shouldn't have access to a gun well
i have
people in my family who are bipolar you
know what happens they get really quiet
and sad and then sometimes they're
really fun to be around
doesn't mean they shouldn't have the
right to own a firearm just like when we
say drug addicts not all drug addicts
are marauding violent thugs george floyd
chose
to be that and i think that we need to
differentiate between yes you're not and
there's also a difference between
you know your your executive functioning
and you know impulsivity
that's not impulsivity i think there is
though a way where you can weigh in
where he comes from yeah a lot of drug
addicts aren't violent but a lot of drug
addicts come from money
and i mean depending on how long that
you have this drug in you and how much
it overtakes you there's just a piece of
your soul going away every single day
and gerald's right it will make you do
things like that that you may think you
can never do you he could believe
that i'm going in there and i'm not
being violent
because i'm not actually going to hurt
her that could be the whatever mental
gymnastics you need to use to get that
fixed
sure now that doesn't excuse it and that
doesn't mean you shouldn't be in prison
right because it certainly means you
should be in prison if you cross that
line
yeah but there needs to be a treatment
that's that for people
on drugs especially if they're going to
be on the street the way that they are
now where it's either
not completely locked up in prison or a
separate drug prison
or a rehab that's actually affordable
yeah that'd be nice
yeah but i think it's important because
this [ __ ] happens when we don't do when
we don't pay attention
to the root of the problem which like
you said loneliness drug addiction
uh and then when you pepper the root of
the problem they just said family i'm
willing to bet didn't have a dad around
george floyd wasn't a dad to his kids so
it perpetuates that vicious cycle i'll
tell you right now i
i was a great kid who did very well in
school up until my dad died or at least
my dad got very sick and was out of the
house
i'm an exact example of that because
there wasn't somebody there that i
needed
right and i understand that and i
understand how much that hurts
i can imagine like look no one is saying
that he didn't have some tough breaks
the issue here is not ever i don't want
everyone to say oh someone's on drugs
and fear them because if you say like oh
they're going to end up being george
floyd right then people are going to be
less likely to stage an intervention
because they're afraid that they get
violent right now i've known plenty of
drug addicts who don't get violent that
way it's a very small percentage of them
and very strong it's a very small and so
we can't just blame it on the drugs at
that point
yeah that's what i'm saying because
that's a disservice to other people who
genuinely
want help doesn't seem like george floyd
wanted it his drug addiction to this
in this moment if that's what we're
trying is
as i mean i hate to say it's as
invaluable as anything else at this
point because you're looking at this
exact moment did this officer
intend to kill him or be completely
unaware well i don't even think that's a
question i don't think he intended
i don't think he did either i think he
knew what he had done in 2019 was the
same thing that he did in 2020 as soon
as the cop comes up he tries to ingest
the drugs oh you're talking about george
floyd he was talking about chaven
yo no i'm saying i think when chavin had
him on the ground george floyd admitted
yeah yeah so why he's i did too many
drugs i think he ate all of it as a
matter of fact there were pills and then
uh i don't know if we have uh
let me let me well let's go really
quickly there were actually this was in
the the trial
uh pills covered and floyd's dna were
discovered in the back of the squad car
uh clip h really quickly
so based on the testing of item 51 and
that known sample
sorry from item 51 that the swab
collected from that
pill i obtained a single source male dna
profile
that matches george floyd uh this
dna profile would not be expected to
occur more than once among unrelated
individuals
in the world population geez all right
so that's really important
so so you're saying there's a chance
yeah
you're right let's go listen to this
lawyer lie some more
and dr tobin who also happens to be a
critical care physician he spent years
treating patients treating patients in
intensive care who
experiencing respiratory failure and
dr tobin literally wrote the book on the
subject and he was able to tell you
i'm pretty sure there's more than one
book this looks like
what he was really wrong about the book
like hey where's your section
respiratory and circulatory systems and
health just the one
it's right over there it's right over
there it's between fiction and
non-fiction because you decide
i'm a big fan of tobin also
oh you mean where do i keep my tobin
and by tobin's i mean multiple copies of
and it's just that image that you see in
like the eleve commercials with a head
and a tube in a circle can you open it
up
the pavement is unyielding and we've got
venus
okay we've got ben asking really quickly
let me uh he's being you know squeezed
in a vise all right so look really
quickly we're going to go this is an
eclectic show we're going to go
back to live fact checking uh the
closing arguments at this trial and let
us know what the hashtag is going on
here
or if no one is actually watching it on
social in which case yeah that is no
hashtag yet wow that is a sad state of
our country
um but right now we have him on the show
he was out he had a uh
a fight on saturday night look obviously
a
a rough night for him but we uh we
wanted to have him on the show wanted to
have him on for a while
you know him as a master of funk ben
askren and uh a wisconsin awa
wisconsin.com is uh where he uh
it's his wrestling wrestling he coaches
kids away did i get this wrong
that's touching yeah well anyway he
coaches kids he's a good guy he's
obviously a multiple time world champion
and here to tell us right now funky ben
ashton how are you sir
i'm doing pretty good how are you i'm
doing all right i know this is a weird
mix don't worry you don't need to talk
about the trial but uh
obviously i'm good yeah i'm nervous
about that because i
haven't been paying any attention so i
don't want to make a comment well
especially also because
you're good friends with tyrone woodley
and so that could be a really rough
sparring session if you two disagree
uh you know what i have a lot of friends
on both sides of the aisle and i just
tell all my friends
i'm gonna respect you no matter what you
think and tyler and i obviously have
very different views on a lot of uh the
world's problems
and we love each other we respect each
other so i don't really
you know there's not issues well there's
not issues there's not issues because
you can kick most people's asses
when i used to do drop-ins and then
someone recognized me from youtube and
held an armbar for about 10 seconds too
long and it popped i said oh i can't do
this anymore
and then i noticed when we were changing
and we had an upside-down cross tattooed
i'm like oh
i thought i tapped um so but i'm not
i'm not funky ben askren so ben i don't
know we don't need to talk about the
obviously i would imagine disappointed
with the results uh with the fight
saturday night
yeah i mean obvious it's the obvious
talking point um and you're more than
welcome to break it up because i
i decided to come on the show so that's
my problem uh yeah
i'm disappointed um just kind of i
didn't spend a lot of time on social
media today i had some high school
friends over we played disc golf
grilled out had a good time um you know
i
some people are just like they don't
think i took it seriously and
here's the thing when i took the fight i
said number one for the money number two
i think it's gonna be a good time i used
to box
you know my friends in high school just
for fun yeah and i trained hard for 11
weeks
i didn't i didn't miss a practice and uh
it just didn't go my way i mean we knew
he had a good overhand right
and i'm a dumbass and i didn't block it
uh my defense was a little too loose
i heard my coaches both tyron and biggie
were saying
stop reacting to his fakes and i didn't
and i
you know i paid the price and um
you know i think one of the things that
really separates me from
a lot of people is like i could have
very easily sat on my couch
and said i don't want to do that because
there's a potential that i'll be
embarrassed
right um and that would be the only
reason i wouldn't have done it there's
no other there's no other valid reason
and i said i'm gonna do it so [ __ ] it
i'm gonna do it yeah i think you and i
are very similar in that way
in that uh i too uh find myself uh
uh unashamed of being embarrassed for
different reasons
um now actually i just noticed quarter
black just lit up when you said disc
golf i guess he's into it too so yeah
i don't know what this is i uh classic i
feel like it's not something an adult
should do
uh by the way you're and i know i know
you're what okay what were you about to
say there ben
i was just gonna say disc golf is uh one
of the greatest activities
it's uh you know it's free in most parks
it costs about 50
to get a set of discs um and it's
something i'm very passionate about so
it's really uh you know maybe it'll just
give you a little more peace and clarity
in your life if you got up to this golf
course and
through 18 holes once in a while well
i'll tell you what maybe we'll do that
for an ash wednesday where you teach me
to disc golf
i've actually never golfed the only golf
i ever did was in in high school and i
was in canadian high school and it was
very cheap
we did wiffle ball golf because they
didn't trust us with actual balls
and i was pretty good at whiffle ball
golf so that's the only golf i've ever
played
and i live near a golf course and i just
so i still get balls in my yard
and what i do is i collect them and i
separate them by brand and then when i
see a ball
go over the fence that symbol of similar
brand i dump that entire bucket of the
brand of ball
just to ruin it they're quite pumped so
golf is way more pretentious
and expensive disc golf just a bunch of
dudes out in the park throwing some
discs
okay uh you know really good crowd of
people okay and by the way your your
podcast too i mean for people who don't
know like you're pretty
pretty unabashedly libertarian supporter
of cryptocurrency which i don't
understand
is it flow wrestling flow wrestling
radio live
so i do ask you three podcasts um i do
i'm on school wrestling
tuesday wednesdays and thursday mornings
i am on
usually we didn't we're not going today
and we're switching to tuesdays but the
funky crypto podcast which i will crypto
and then i do an mma one with a guy
named from brian who got kicked off
twitter unfairly
um i remember him and we just kind of go
whenever we feel like it we don't really
have a schedule just
once in a while okay so let me ask you
this i don't want to talk about since
just like you said you know
you you just uh through to my face you
don't want to talk about the fight can i
ask you about this though did you talk
about it that event
was and i hope you don't take offense
this was
legitimately the worst thing i've ever
seen in my life it set
an entire generation back i mean i was
watching it going
so is this just women just hump and
tweezers
i scolded the owner of the business when
they came to my locker room
it was that's all live on camera i just
i i don't know if you saw the one where
the one the guy
uh the person of color and the one floor
of the cuckoo's nest had his
hat he was yelling [ __ ] was his that
was his catchphrase [ __ ] and this girl
is in a mesh body suit
she turns around grabs with her fingers
and spreads the bottom of her butt
cheeks like how's that person gonna tell
their kids to be home at curfew
i don't understand i uh um no
i did i don't recall seeing that part
but yeah i mean so uh pete davis had to
interview me
and the behind the cameras was i believe
the
executive producer of the show um
pete davidson was no pete davis
interviewed me oh yeah he sat down okay
and then the executive produced the show
was like behind the camera
okay and i said hey man uh bert bert hey
i
you know i have a lot of my wrestling
kids watching this i mean
my brother and i own five academies i
can't even imagine what their parents
are thinking right now i feel so
effing guilty that their parents are
either having to like kick them out or
like explain to them what what the hell
is going on right here
or they've been banging on the bathroom
door for the last hour and a half going
get out now
yeah um yeah i mean i and i like to be
kind of socially liberal but
oh that was uh no no no this is beyond
socially liberal like i was you couldn't
do this in a strip club
in the 70s uh and i just and i mean i
was i honestly thought i'm not going to
make it to your fight
it was about it was about two and a half
hours there was no no fight
yeah the first fight was a dj versus a
boxer which was
really really strange um yeah but then
it was it was
a very long time till the next fight
came up um
mostly musical performances and dancing
and yeah i
you know i maybe i'm america's dad but i
did find the
entertainment to be very distasteful and
actually i think everyone in my locker
room kind of felt
similarly really and these are fighters
but here's the thing what are you going
to do in you know 10 years when your
kids grow up they're going to find this
on the internet and i'm like oh let me
go watch some of dad's old fights
and they'll have to get through you know
140 minutes of stripping
i'm sure i'm sure they could just type
type in the name of the fight and they
would find just the
just the clip i'm sure i'm sure they're
not gonna need to watch the whole
production
uh so that that was positive i i mean
obviously there's there's the obvious
that i'm sure kids are finding worse
than this on youtube
uh and instagram unfortunately uh but
yeah i didn't love it
no i can't i just i i felt genuinely
depressed
when i was watching i was going oh my
gosh if this is what i've heard of
people being out of touch
with the youth culture but i was like
this is a you know this is not beetles i
want to hold your hand or i was saying
even going back to salt and pepper you
know push it that was considered
scandalous
it was back when it happened push it
good put and then then i'm watching it
my wife this is the truth i go hey you
have to watch this this is a disaster
because everyone's high at the the which
i assume the
executive producer was too they said
sweetheart you got to come up everyone's
high everyone's drunk this is this is
going to like i'm tuning in for the
fight this is crazy
and then she walks up and then it's just
letting go man put your teammate and
then she goes
oh what are you watching and i'm like i
swear it wasn't this when before
before you came up there was a it was a
fight it was 20 minutes
of just undulation uh my wife my wife
was hoping that kanye and bieber would
do a sunday service to redeem
redeem what we watched on saturday night
i you know what
i don't i don't personally smoke pot but
i don't have anything
really against it for certain adults but
the the glorification of it was
was kind of strange to me i mean they
were really
putting it up there on a pedestal and
that was like kind of eye roll
yeah well it was because you had oscar
de la hoya that's what happens when you
combine uppers and downers
as soon as that's like yeah oscar would
have been doing some other stuff yeah he
was
he didn't even get it in the name where
he's going go ussr baby and there's a
guy was on the navy ship uss fa
he's a ussr baby go go buy me ussr like
does he think he's watching rocky
iv so uh anyway well listen uh ben
i know it's been a it's a weird day
today and look i i really appreciate you
you
getting in there and taking uh taking a
swing at it and look let's do uh a
segment here in the future where you can
teach me
disc golf and i'll be sure to not enjoy
it
but be a good sport you might really
enjoy where do you guys live
uh we're in the general state of texas
yeah so there's a lot of great districts
are you
but you're still in wisconsin right so
i'm in michigan austin
austin i don't come on i'm not going to
do that right now terrorists are
watching but i uh i spend a lot of time
saying like the general of the city
austin's like 60 miles wide
well listen you know what uh i'm i don't
know you know what let's just just put a
pin
in where alex jones is in austin i just
assumed that i lived there but i'm in
in the midwest quite a bit you know all
my family they live in michigan uh
i was born in michigan and you know the
u.p is ours sorry about that wisconsin
so you know
it's a little beard it's really it's
really really really weird that that
that belongs to michigan
i know yeah i know but oh well
enjoy your non-u.p wisconsin we'll be in
touch we'll do the disc golf and
again that's uh where's your where's
your twitter uh ben where people can
find you
it's just been asking on everything uh i
got 23 holds of disc golf at my house
uh not open to the public but you're
invited if you want to come stephen
uh and then my brother i own five
wrestling academies and
you know the other day people were upset
that i was smiling afterwards my wife
i told all of you people before i took
this fight i don't give a [ __ ] about the
result when i'm in there i'm going to
try to fight hard
but the other day on monday i'm going to
go back to podcasting and coaching
wrestling
yeah and my wife said something fun to
me and i laughed and people are upset
about it they need to they really need
to get a life and i think they're trying
to
export their own emotions on me well i
think if anything they should be more
upset about the fact that after uh jake
paul
uh won he sobbed like he had just
defeated marvin hagler
also i didn't get the in memoriam it's
like they have dmx and then
also shadow and i was like well that's a
jake paul's bodyguard and it's sad but
this is just
everything is weird so all right uh
funky ben thank you so much we'll be in
touch brother appreciate it uh
rest up have a great day you too bye all
right let's go back to the i like i said
it's a weird mix today
yeah i just nobody ever done a sketch
it's just so
sad dmx is dead i know where were you
going with this
i was going to say just get real
surprised
that they're trying to make the case for
second-degree murder oh okay sorry
but then we'll go back to your uh dmx
sketch which i'm sure is uh
light entertainment you go to the dmv
but it's dmx
anything else get it that he did not
consent to this now
the state does not have to prove what we
don't have to prove about intent we
don't have to show
that the defendant intended to cause
george floyd harm don't have to show
that
you don't need to find it but you said
he meant to so you do
now because you said he meant to you
said he did it on purpose
that he meant to win so it does matter
because of you
but just in case you don't believe us
yeah oh the loopty loops
you don't have to show that the
defendant intended to kill him the only
thing that the the
the only thing about defendant's intent
that we have to prove
is that he applied force to george floyd
on purpose that this wasn't an
accident and it's pretty simple you know
if you're doing something that hurts
somebody and you know it
and you keep doing it you're doing it on
purpose
you put your right knee in take your
right knee out
no about i guess i know what segment
just made the
news yeah for us somebody's telling you
they can't breathe and you keep doing it
he said he couldn't breathe before he
got in the car
well so does 98 of the people who get
pulled over now so that doesn't really
exactly apply everybody knows what
happens
when you push somebody they yell and
breathe and they toss
the spray paint can to the graffiti
artist for the mural
this is my good side that's that's
awesome
please jesus christ i'm sorry i know you
guys don't like that word
salt in the third degree absolutely
requires that the defendant inflicted
substantial bodily harm
that was just road rash on his fingers
uh yeah but
a temporary and that's what happens i
mean i don't know again this is all
predicated on the idea that cops
shouldn't do anything
that is uncomfortable or unpleasant i
don't understand i don't understand this
if you kick a cop and you are actively
resisting arrest and you are on concrete
you should expect a little bit of
of rug burn none of that is relevant
substantial bodily harm i had worse from
when
gibbon handcuffed me the wrong way
that's true you came in here with some i
had i had some red wrists
it was like there were those marks like
i had slept on a waffle iron
well his his fingers were ripped open
well i was ripped open here
was it yeah you bet it looks ripped he's
unconscious
it's a workout called dabble proprietary
i'd love to be a spotter i don't uh i
don't lift much weight but i like to
watch
try to break chauncey
second degree murder defendant caused
george floyd's death he did
the state proved that beyond a
reasonable doubt
i didn't know and at the time of course
you stopped calling yourself the state
yeah yeah they didn't prove it be
unreasonable this guy is really i mean i
guess i'm surprised that they're just
allowed to be this dishonest
in closing so it's like where you come
from right if you came into this
thinking he was guilty then yeah of
course everything they said
just lined up with your view but if you
came in objectively you have some
questions
yeah well i'm just saying everything
that he just said is dishonest in the
sense that he said you know he called he
called for his mother no he was trying
to call his girlfriend
he uh he uh you know he had been taking
a bunch of drugs so he had a tolerance
but you said that he actually didn't
have a tolerance he allegedly
counterfeit no was actually counterfeit
so it's just i'm not talking about the
opinion
as to whether george floyd whether
shaving not
effectively turning over and performing
cpr
on george floyd i'm not talking about
the opinion that that is what a police
officer should do in that scenario
i'm talking about the misstatements that
are verifiably false that he's made
if this if we were actually to have an
honest conversation here look
if you remove the riots okay you remove
the pressure from maxine waters if you
remove
the defund the police movement you take
all of us away this would distill to and
it would be a very boring trial
it would distill to look cop was well
within his right to do what he did you
have a serial felon he was committing a
crime right there
he was actively resisting arrest they
tried to put him in a cop cause they
tried to put him in the car he refused
to go in
he swallowed a bunch of drugs his drugs
were this was a level of drugs in his
system
he had congenital heart disease he had
arthrosclerosis
he had covid while he was on the ground
he was claiming he couldn't breathe but
he already claimed that and it would
really just come down to
okay what is the police protocol if you
have someone
on the ground and at a certain and they
stop moving when you're surrounded by a
crowd and waiting for paramedics it
really should come down for that are you
required by police protocol
at that point to yourself perform cpr
and the answer to that and it was very
clear in the trial is
in some scenarios you're actually not
forbidden but you're actually advised
not to if there's a potentially unruly
crowd so that the paramedics can do
their job and you can get people to
disperse
that's what this really should distill
to
and is a conversation where we could all
have opinions well look okay i think
that
and maybe the problem there lies with
the police department not training
people properly
the problem is you can never have an
honest conversation when you've lit a
powder keg
and right now everyone is afraid they're
afraid that if they don't convict this
guy
on second degree murder first-degree
murder that these jurors they're afraid
they're going to be responsible
for another two dozen deaths right for
another
what is it five six seven hundred
officer casualties for another two
billion dollars in damages to businesses
these jurors right that's the problem
they're not listening to the actual
facts of the case
this is charged by design because of the
maxine waters of the world well i agree
with that yeah i think really what it
comes down to in the meat of this is
we need to just get rid of firefighters
and when there's riots call a twerk
engine and they can come and put
everything out with their whop
yes that's a great idea though it's
really what's a great idea
to have a public uh public stockpile of
penicillin but sure yeah well yeah i
mean
you don't want to you don't want to
touch any of the lumber for a few days
exactly were you about to say something
yeah so far on twitter the only thing
trending is steve
schlecker the name of the prosecutor but
also
you know we we just said he's trying
he's trying to prove uh second-degree
murder and we have this from the
minnesota office of the reviser of
statutes
um secondary murder causes the death of
a human being without intent to affect
the death of any person while committing
or attempting to commit
a felony offense other than criminal
sexual conduct
so that's what they have to prove that
he was trying to commit a felony offense
why does it exclude felony sexual
conduct that's a good question like if
you like it's like oh no no it's not
second degree murder
i was just trying to rape this broad
like oh i'm just trying to give you
sorry
i'm such a slap on the wrist i'm just
doing me baby i don't know
are you giving any second-degree murder
no no no she's a hooker
oh okay oh it's fine you can kill those
for free
well your rap sheets loaded with loaded
with dead hookers i don't know what you
yeah it's not a real that's not a second
degree murder
how do you get a refund from a hooker
huh you kill her right
right all right i'm gonna go i believe
that's a second degree murder
really if anything it's second-degree
robbery what's she chart what the hook
have charged me
so anyways that's probably the least but
it is weird to me that they exclude the
felony sexual assault
however it does show that someone needs
to be committing a felony for it to be
secondary murder right yelling the
assault
felony assault in which case guess what
why do you think they're having a hard
time recruiting police officers
right now because people keep killing
them yeah because people keep killing
them
not only that but you're worried now
when you got into your job if i try and
restrain somebody and they happen to be
hopped up on drugs
it could be felony assault and
second-degree murder yeah who would take
that risk at this point i wouldn't
i mean they need to at least put 50
bucks out to the applicants
they might no i really do feel bad for a
lot of police officers which is words
that i thought i would never say
yeah and as i've grown up and been an
adult and taken responsibility for my
own shortcomings
you have to realize that the police are
there for a reason and defunding them is
one of the dumbest things i've ever
heard
yeah well part of me thinks that when
they're arresting people for defending
themselves against antifa it's like all
right you know what
defund them let the cards fall where
they may you kneelers before blm and
arresters of ladies wearing double masks
so just so you i'm not saying that
police are your friends
all the time and police who are willing
to go along with the state and remove
your liberties
that's a problem too and that's why we
have a second amendment someone
shouldn't be allowed to come into your
house or like they do in canada and say
do you have more than three people here
we're going to arrest you we're going to
break up your place of worship yeah
ontario thing is
ridiculous it's a police state right it
is it really is the closest when people
throw
nazi all the time like you voted for
trump you're a nazi i don't know i think
when
people in masks and guns show up
and shut down your church and threaten
arresting that's as close to the gestapo
as you guys
tell the neighbors to call and other
people well obviously it got worse they
can now stop you for no reason
whatsoever to find out why you're out
from your home
yeah whether you have a mask on or not
it's disgusting
it looks like the prosecution's about to
say that chevin was on his neck
okay all right let's go indifference
the defendant ever listen
ever consider medical attention
the paramedics were already called the
emt
decision the failure to give cpr not
even
dr fowler this isn't protection
this isn't courage and it certainly
certainly
is not and was not compassion it was the
opposite
of that
so back to the instructions everything
here is an emotional plea
you know who else didn't give cpr if i
remember correctly when you're
delivering the paramedics they loaded
them up first
right and then did cpr in the bus
because it was too dangerous on the
street sons of [ __ ]
i like how now there's no problem
explaining voting
absolutely the state proved that
no i wonder if they ask any of those
jurors for picture ideas
consisting of reckless disregard
for human life a conscious indifference
to the loss of life no limb difference
that the dangerous that the eminently
dangerous act could cause
yes he did
and you will find well how do you have a
reckless disregard for human life and
then
intentional which is what they have up
top so how do you check both of them
either it was intentional
or was it disregarded and it was
reckless
someone can't be intentionally reckless
there's a fifth element
have you ever seen me dance son
with what i just called dad wedding
dance yeah right
sorry guys i'm intentionally reckless
hey you guys hey
first degree ripping up a rug
i really can't dance that sounds like a
disney uh one-liner like
some some chipmunk or something like
that yeah first degree you're whipping
up a wrap
shake what your mama gave you turn the
left alvin yeah i have a kid
don't think i don't watch elven in the
chipmunks movies i just watched
chipwrecked recently oh really yeah yeah
oh wow that's not the worst thing you
can watch
well you know what you really uh now i
think i could watch the beginning of
this
this is a this is a looking glass into
my future i think i need to go home and
turn my wife into a real life
lifetime movie just hey look stairs
oh no eric roberts and meredith baxter
bernie in uh oh stairs charlie
my stairs just standing in front of an
empty staircase trying to go up
there's one hey name that movie referee
don't
yeah of course i know it's one of it's
one of the best
a lot of people don't know it biden has
to have something to follow up
it's true that's true and
with the defendant and his specialized
knowledge about the dangers of
positional asphyxia
and the common sense that if you put
your knee on somebody's neck
there's a strong probability of injury
he knew that too
great bodily harm bodily injury that
creates a high probability of death
uh nope nope then you are blaming the
police department because it's been used
several hundred times and this is how
they teach people again
you can disagree you can have a problem
with that control position
i do mainly because it's not very
effective anyone out there who's done
high school college wrestling or has
gotten to a blue belt in brazilian
anyone out there let me know judo you
know that's not a pin that would work
that's my problem with it however
my problem is with why is zach playing
that's a pin
how my problem is with the police
department
training people that way it's not good
training so if you're upset about it you
also need to understand the target of
your ire
it's not shove it yeah especially if
he's done it several times
and not had any problems i have no idea
if that's the case but i'm i'm guessing
it is not the first time
hundreds of officers have yeah because
they were also and thought that
they didn't die right yeah i just think
there is the possibility if he did know
him and didn't like him
well he just said he didn't know him it
means that you have to use your
knowledge he did yeah the prosecutor
said that yeah when he said he didn't
know him and so he just called he
had no idea who he was officer well then
what's all that i've been hearing where
were you
that's the point we were making i know
i'm kidding i know
exactly 119 you take a look at all of
the in-services all of the hours
right he knew what to do he just didn't
do it
he knew better he didn't do better what
does that is
cpr he wouldn't even let genevieve
hansen the off-duty firefighter
wasn't that biden's campaign slogan he
wasn't going to do it himself
build back better i don't know better i
don't know better building
rocks in my brain bob the building the
knowledge it was exploring doors
so when you consider this journey
about your husband let me touch your
kid's face
where you took it come on come on let me
smell i took a chance
that's only you know it's only stiffer
it's just nice
we're all doing it now man i need you to
pull over at this park i gotta go uh
sniff the swings
so uh not the after that the wooden ones
uh the
you know the rubber one it's porous
they keep my secrets
finding the murdered was committed the
manslaughter was committed
you have another thing to consider and
that is
was this just okay was this fine
is this okay because the defendant was a
police officer
was this a authorized use of force
was it justified was it justified it was
not
oh i thought he was asking me hmm
i had some time to i was pondering where
he was going
i didn't know we had mr walking cheat
sheet over here
i thought he was ordering a sandwich
with that stupid glass cage he's in
i hate it every time i see it no one's
going to get germs at this
murder trial
would have known
to see whether these actions the
defendant's actions
were objectively reasonable
witness said yes well not only that not
objectively reasonable
is it were they objectively taught to
the police department yeah
no the expert witness even used those
words right crowl
used those words and said it was an
objectively reasonable
use of force germs aren't six feet and
under
um they can go up
i'm just saying the whole thing is
annoying doesn't make any sense
his lies it's called the germ nino
effect
oh that's true if they get high enough
depending on the temperature of the room
and then all of a sudden what is that is
that a flying humboldt squid
that's weird a little marine biology
humor there oh
i like this all right play this i gotta
pee you guys all left and peed and i'm
the only one who didn't keep it going i
figured we were gonna be here i didn't
pee but i did go into the bathroom
right boys no all right you're a
terrible person
i was giving the heimlich to someone you
know the problem was
what there's like superhumans you don't
ever do that no
go to the bathroom and just give someone
the heimlich who's not ready for it stop
it dave
stop it sneak up behind him and go you
look like you need the heimlich
come on gerald come on gerald don't
accept
any motion to the contract cheryl how
tall are you 6'4
yeah that's good i could barely even
have to kneel down that'll work
i don't think this is what stephen i
think maybe all i'm saying is
we go to the bathroom you get the
heimlich i bring a step ladder
let's get weird come on man gotta be
doing come on all right let's listen to
the guy
disappoint your lord
but under the law you don't look at it
from the defendant's perspective either
yeah you do that's the other side of it
and the evidence in this case has shown
over
and over that the defendant is not that
officer because he did not act as a
reasonable officer really
does anyone else hate that woman's shoes
as much as i do
they just it's like what are they
sandals are they not going on there make
a choice
and live with it i bet you that i
guarantee you there's just vodka in that
bottle too
it's water it's a long day here and
lawyers like to blow v8
just knowing when she pulls out it's
like i might have to just drive
into 80 people lighting the city on fire
might as well have a party while doing
it that was his justification for using
this level of force
he's a big guy he's a sizeable guy and
he might be on something
we have to control him yeah control is
the restraint
so that's the force yes that just makes
sense to justifications
where that george floyd was big and that
he might be
on something which he was know the
standards
you've heard the standards he outweighed
shoving by 50 pounds
you know the difference between a risk
and a threat
officers are all bigger than you would
be a threat
right yeah i mean just floored by like
60 pounds or 70 pounds right because the
gear on i think floyd with all his gear
was 183 so not just body weight
yeah he was a big guy big small i'm
sorry
yeah with all the stuff not everybody's
a threat being
large the actual i'm heavier than
shaving because i don't eat right
the act hold on the point he's making
right now that being big is not a crime
tell that to test holiday yeah tell that
to me because everybody acts like
no shortage
yeah no kidding i thought you didn't
like that stuff
transcribed
and all their
he got a head injury he was cleaning the
whop stage last week and
slipped nobody cares about that brandon
all right let me watch it what did i
miss anything important were you guys no
not really
dave was going to do untold things to me
and that's not i was just simply asking
if i could meet him in the men's room
you know what by the way we can take
some of the mug club chat since
we're going a little bit late today
we'll still go to mug club only live
credit dot com
mug club but if we want to bring up some
mug club chat as this goes on
that way people on youtube know that uh
we don't allow the youtube chat because
we don't want to give them any more
support than we have filthy all right
let me go on with this
and the language hypotheticals talked
about a lot of stuff that didn't happen
you need to focus on presenting a case
did happen i'd pay a hundred bucks if he
just got
everything that guy said is [ __ ]
thank you couldn't you just yeah
thank you have you been drinking i've
had a few chardonnays whatever
they had him handcuffed is it mimosa
drinking come on it's a breakfast thing
right guys it's got oj in it yeah who
wants to get loose
i have those old little uh little
crystal uh sherry glasses with a hard
boiled egg yeah
yeah you'll usually leave the egg hey
short pants girl with the dumb clogged
shoes
do you wanna you wanna have a mimosa
with me
in my van pressing down on him
continuing to twist his arm
twist his wrist that would buck up
against the handcuff
a pain compliance technique without the
opportunity to comply
is simply the what what
what are you out of your tree sir
think about no ability to comply yeah
get in the car
no we're going to leave the window open
no we're going to turn in the air no
kick to the officer they put them down
if you're not allowed this is this is my
point and
and dave i know you land up here but
this is this is my point i think this is
very important
if you don't believe that in that
scenario an officer
can use a compliance technique you don't
believe that police officers
have the right to use compliance
techniques it's like when they say why
don't you just use a taser but then they
say don't use a taser listen if you
don't believe that someone has the right
to use their firearm
when someone else is running away from
the police and has a gun
and turns to it doesn't matter if he
drops the gun then you don't believe
that police should ever have a firearm
if you don't believe that you can use a
compliance technique when someone has
actively resisted arrest
is larger than you has kicked a cop and
refused to get in the car
then you don't believe that cops you
just think they should say hey you're
under arrest and you say no and they say
i apologize i've actually got some body
cam footage even even
floyd's friends were like hey just sit
down yeah just comply all right let's
bring up that footage
okay stay put all right let's see what
my partner does
damn he still won't get in the car just
sit down dude
but they wouldn't want to use a
compliance technique
and by the way if it was dangerous
walking while black then those people
would have been hurt yeah you know what
happened he said get up against the wall
the one lady didn't have id the other
guy right away gave him ideas he stepped
out because apparently black people do
do have id oh that's right he gave it to
him and he said all right just can you
stand over there he said yep and then
she said
he's crazy which by the way some people
are going she told him he was crazy and
i'm going
yeah i'm a cop and she told me he's
crazy
so now i'm more on guard is that is that
an excuse to not believe them yo
we said he was crazy but then i guess
he's free to go
well that really does destroy the
narrative of everybody was screaming
that it was brutality though yeah it
really does
well that was yeah that was at the start
of it and then afterwards when he was
down on the ground that's when people
who weren't there for the meet up start
going oh man you look like they didn't
know get off him
well that's what it is up until that
point with chalvin
right but what i'm yeah but what i'm
saying is it got unruly because then a
crowd started surrounding oh no i get
that yeah yeah but early on they were
just like
like they had been there before yeah you
could tell they were they were
exasperated they were exhausted i think
they are
yes and rightfully so and this is during
a lot of
other shootings that happen in riots
happening
so the police are aware the crowd is
aware they're
getting more aggressive so you don't
know what's going on let's see what
they're saying now because now that this
is when the crowd starts to form
concern uh yeah the defendant doesn't
appear
too concerned it wasn't the
just a show i don't want to be
uh interrupted is that this the little
girl who's supposed to not be shown in
any
and everything well they've already
shown her like 15 times right but
uh yeah she's okay of i'm done
year old are being filmed by some
civilians there's a policy about filming
they understand that civilians can film
them i think
they know that it's right there this
isn't something new
or earth shattering or or even
particularly
noteworthy sergeant steiger
you recall him from lapd he used a
patrol
on skid row he talked about people
throwing rocks and bottles
this is they have a phone of phones
they're expressing concern they're not
doing anything
they were yelling they were going to f
him up and this is an incredibly high
crime area and the cops knew that going
into it come on
don't act like these are just bystanders
going oh well that looks terrible i
can't believe that the police would do
something like oh yeah it's high crime
have you seen the prices at cup foods
highway robbery neri a usda organic
label to be found
no shameful a dollar for a banana
no two for a dollar why is it gonna be a
banana
well that's what they have cup uh oh did
i do it again no he did it michael
how dare you the chief of police
right that this conduct the 929
violates the use of force policy
violates
the department's core values
he violated his duty of care
he failed to render aid
remember commander now inspector katie
blackwell who
who was in charge of all training looked
at this and said i don't even know what
this
is i don't know what this modification
is
this isn't how they train this
these aren't the rules well the book
disagrees with you yes
in writing yeah in writing and pictures
it was a pop just in case yeah you
remember the section
it's a whole section of one book
it is not we don't trust i hate
court so much i'm sorry it's just so
he's so boring well you know what today
you're in your paycheck yeah how about
the chase you cut to it
on that date so long at that time
if i'm a juror i'm like i'm going to
find him not guilty just so he can leave
can we vote now uh i'm ready to vote
your honor
it's the litigation equivalent of peter
jackson yeah
yeah it's like i don't know how long you
think it's gonna take to uh how do you
think
this shot's gonna go about four seconds
i think in 40 seconds
why not also he's making a big deal of
9.29 but remember originally it was
reported 846.
yeah right so
not reasonable only reasonable force is
authorized
this was that so he is classified as
deadly force
so also not to mention the pain
compliance move of slightly twisting his
wrist
like you talked about the movie
philadelphia just think of
denzel washington's wrapping up
arguments in like a minute
yeah people are clapping
they're happy to go home and not guilty
and you got that
guilty his hearts in it that's never how
it goes it would in real life you know
you'd be a few good members like
you want me out you want me on that wall
and i'm like all right okay well thanks
for the outburst
uh follow-up what were you doing at 9 42
a.m
i was eating cereal okay and then at 9
56
and that's about it yeah well i had
finished my cereal
you can't handle the truth but i do have
another uh
hour 42 minutes so i apologize the
crescendo was ill-timed
do you mean poor do you guys believe in
ghosts it might inherit your body that
were once aliens
i do i'm tom cruise and i'm in the
closet was defendant kneeling on mr
floyd's neck and back
at 8 22 24. my stomach hurts my neck
hurts anything everything hurts
defendant heard that he heard those
words my back my [ __ ] and my crap
george
sorry that seriously just fell out of my
mouth
steven's gonna like his uh like his bag
of speed balls
now finish finish your speed balls
or you don't get your heroin you can't
how can you have any pudding if you
don't eat your speed
you can't have your pudding
look it's just we live in different
worlds they're also trying to speak to
jurors and to people in america who
think
it's like you don't live in a world
where you've actively
armed strong-armed and violently robbed
a woman with her kid in the house
and then lived on drugs your whole life
committed felonies
selling counterfeit bills then try to
hide a speed ball in your mouth
these are the kinds of people that
police officers encounter on a daily
basis and so if you and the problem now
is we're making it seem like police
officers this prosecution maxine waters
that they're going to approach
everyone the way that they approached
george floyd
by the way rightfully so certainly in
their approach we can argue the last
minute and a half but certainly in their
approach with someone who is violent if
they want to go home
to their families and so now you have
kids out there thinking
oh i just get pulled over for a speeding
ticket and i'm going to get shot lit up
statistics don't show that to be true
they actually show it to be more true if
you're white than black with police
officers by the way statistics show that
police officers are anywhere from 16 to
18 times more likely to be
shot by a criminal like george floyd
than them to actually kill said criminal
this is reality and so people now are
copy pasting well i wouldn't want that
to happen to me
did you did you slip counterfeit bills
did you did you rob a woman at gunpoint
in front of her kid
were you were you developing a crazy
high tolerance with your crack fiend
girlfriend did you lie to the cops
did you spit did you try and swallow a
speed ball and then spit it out if not
that's probably not going to happen to
you what's more likely
is the two other passengers who were in
the car who were up against the wall and
he said can i have some idea right just
stay back and i said okay
quit resisting man that's how most
interactions go
but if you now tell young black men that
they're all going to get the george
floyd treatment
without giving them context regardless
of whether mistakes were made
you are going to create but we already
have a powder kick we're gonna write no
matter what yeah
well and you've also created a scenario
where you you're almost guaranteed not
to have a fair trial because if you're a
juror right now
can you imagine this jury comes back
let's assume they come back not guilty
can you imagine the outcry people
will find out who these jurors were and
their lives would be over
ryan stealth will beat him with his
purse his european man bag
it's a murse you are right though i mean
every one of them now has to worry about
being doxxed
their family's being hurt i mean it's
really well the one expert witness was
they just painted his a
house in a pig's blood or they they left
a pig's head they left a pig
is this the uh uh crawl guy i can't
remember
yeah it's crawl yeah they left kathy
bates head on his front porch
yeah that's not nice nobody deserves
very bright
very actually they were doing him a
favor because the firstborns and the
rest of the block died
ah wow what was looking out for them did
they they left
a biblical humor yeah pig's head they
left the pig's head
yeah we're right back we're right back
to john lennon and uh the piggies and
the helter skelter and
have you seen little little piggies
playing in the dick
it's like well they were i wasn't
singing about cops what about this
always in starch shirts that doesn't
sound like piggies
it's the alternate ending to babe pig in
the city
where they do that they keep showing
this girl
this underage girl they're not supposed
to i know they're not supposed to show
like ah crap we screwed up earlier here
she is
there you go yeah just let it fly all
right let me let go back and listen to
them sorry we gotta hear which one by
fate
at one single moment in time
to witness something to witness
nine minutes and 29 seconds
that girl ripped those pants from the
grimace
abuse of authority mcdonald's to watch a
man
die and there was nothing they could do
about it
because they were powerless they were
utterly powerless because even they
respected the badge even seeing this
happening they tried
they cried out at first pointed out hey
you can get up off him
it became more and more desperate as
they watched us go on and
on and on and there was nothing there
was
nothing they could do all they could do
like this was watch and gather what they
could
gather their memories which were wrong
proven in court gather those precious
recordings
and they gathered those up and they
brought them here
and they brought them here and they got
up on the stand and they testified
when they were questioned it often
didn't hold up they were wrong
facts matters outrageous act they became
a part of the
the scene gave you what they had did you
guys notice
last night how white the country music
awards were so you can see i didn't
watch them
well good there was no appearance from
that to you uh darius rucker right
he'll always be hooty to me i don't know
i never watched that stuff
he will always be hoodie to me no i once
met a blowfish
well he said he was randomly selected
people
that's my favorite jerry maguire line
when rod tidwell his kid goes up for an
autograph
yeah man he goes you hootie and here you
are no i'm not
hoodie
no before you couldn't put that in the
script
because it would be accused of being
racist well if any black guy puts on a
cowboy hat you know what might be said
to you during the day
let's be honest it's just i might call
you
for us i only want to be with you to use
appropriately
but sometimes we take it back sometimes
when something is really important
we reserve those decisions for ourselves
the state
we have power too much power way way way
too much power
there's power but he cannot the judge
the judge just has his turtle mask over
his eyes
ah that power belongs to you he's
blushing through the mask
i do have power and only you i am
powerful
i'm wonderful people like i have
the power just kissing the judge's ass
he has powerful legs powerful legs
because you could pass for gay i don't
mean in a sexual way just you know you
got that cut
look yeah look totally not like the 90s
where they were kind of puffy you know
like 98 degrees and backstreet boys were
like 90s fit you look like
like gay fit you know like the nice uh
where it comes to a nice point here
nice uh the [ __ ] gutters they they
beautiful thank you
that's so pg-13 i was objecting to
gutters
i guess at this point when kids are
watching whap that's
from the triller fight club there is
nothing i've done that as bad as what
you showed me today
well i have dance like that once or
twice for money
thank you very little money all right so
he just wrapped up
just wrapped up thank god
i lie that's about all we've got ugh
simon my friend simon and garfunkel
yeah before they split up yeah he had
garfunkel in when i did arthur
did you really it was during the phase
where everyone was specifically
instructed to not even utter the name
paul simon how was he i didn't i
actually wasn't there the day was
recording
you're like i don't even need to meet
that yeah
i don't need the less i don't need the
lesser of silent garfunkel there are
only two
how'd those solo careers go yeah tell
oates that i'll be
oh can we hear what they have to say
about this yeah let's hear let's hear
what they have to say
really fast we got this from a
washington post article that just came
out
um oh what's gonna happen now is a
20-minute break then the defense will go
another 20 minute break a rebuttal
another 20 minute break and instructions
to the jury well when's the
probably going for a little while when's
the puppy bowl i said when's the puppy
bowl
all right well here look here's what
we'll do i'm going to wrap up a couple
of things here that i wanted to go to
earlier in the show map
and then we will go to mug club only and
cover some of the defense
um so let me go back to this we just we
showed you early on
and i think this matters regardless of
what cnn is talking about look
what's real what should concern
everybody here because you could also be
someone
sitting in that hot seat at some point
um not only could you be someone of
course people always
say put yourself in george floyd's shoes
sure however
you also have to put yourself in the
decision-making process of george floyd
that led up to that and then in this
case this is something that sort of fell
on derek shawn's doorstep right you have
to put yourself in those shoes
and understand that at some point
particularly now or not only if you're a
cop
a business owner if you're a man who
can't get through
uh to your home because of rioters and
protesters
you may be on trial for simply hitting
the gas pedal on your car
so let me go back to this we uh earlier
today i'm trying to see we had brian
stelter purse
uh okay so
let me show you this this is like i was
talking about with the cops who um
aren't necessarily always our friends
this could be you here's an example of a
man who is trying to get to his house
right now and this is the powder keg
that's been lit right you just saw
maxine waters we showed you before the
show where she was saying they need to
be more confrontational and to be in the
streets
harass them she said right don't let
them go
make sure you get a mob tell them
they're not welcome
and so now you have people with an
excuse to commit wanton acts of violence
without any repercussions
now what happens if this comes to your
neighborhood
what do you do if you're well with you
could be well within your rights
to simply drive home but if you exercise
your constitutional rights you end up
being the one arrested
here's an example of uh stillwater
minnesota there was a guy who was trying
to get home
because protesters blocked a cul-de-sac
it doesn't even look like an er i don't
even know
how this is a protester a protest um
clip f the guy gets arrested
he's just trying to get home
as an angry motorist who refused to move
his car
the police were on the scene and lo and
behold
a miracle of god they took him away put
him in the back of the squad car
they moved his vehicle out of the street
so we can peacefully continue
our march aren't you supposed to be
marching when you march like if you were
marching it wouldn't be that big a deal
it's like it's just like a duck crossing
and you're like okay they go past and
then you get no you were blocking the
road
and the guy ended up selling them you
know they got into a scuffle no one was
punched
and the cop struck him in the back of
the paddy wagon she doesn't look like
marching as one of her hobbies no
not exactly not used to it she might put
it on the dating app and you go
really swipe long marches on the beach
free nike long marches and by that i
mean sitting on the sidewalk or in the
middle of the road in your cul-de-sac
i can block traffic i can block well she
that looks like she'd be very effective
oh yeah
if it was the march the marching team
should be picked last
if it was the blocking traffic blocking
as much of the lane with the least
amount of people possible
she'd be number one pick she could be a
professional soccer goalie without even
playing
ever just whip just whip her hair just
go stand there
uh let me show this again we showed this
early on but i want to show clipsy of
maxine waters because again this is
this is what she's saying right now she
is directly trying to affect
the outcome of the jury and then i'm
going to compare it with
uh the repercussions we've seen with
donald trump so clipsy maxine waters had
this to say in minnesota
this weekend should be federally charged
impeached and should be put in prison
fight for justice but i am very hopeful
and i hope that we're going to get
a verdict that is a guilty guilty
and if we don't we we cannot go away and
not just manslaughter right i mean
oh no not bachelor no no no no no no no
no it couldn't be reasonable
i don't know whether it's in the first
degree but as far as i'm concerned is
what happens if we do not go get what
you just told what should the people do
what's your protesters on the street
i didn't hear you what happens what
should protesters do
well we gotta stay on the street uh and
we've got to get
more active you've got to get more
confrontational
we've got to make sure that they they
know that we need business
yeah stay on the street that's wonderful
advice for kids coming from the lady who
got her mask
trimmed off the left side of two faces
suit
it is amazing that she's wearing that
much stuff on her face to protect
herself from a germ
but she has no problem telling other
people to go out and hurt others right
exactly what is it what does it mean
that's because her movie is like the
sixth sense where she finds that at the
end she's like
i was the germ all along the whole time
um
and then and then there was a police
there was a shooting right against
police and drive-by shooting right after
that we don't show that clip but then
again i just want to reiterate this
because
this is a long-standing history of
maxine waters and you see similar things
from aoc
just maxine waters is around the bend
enough that she doesn't even know that
she's supposed to veil it
yeah she just says blow [ __ ] up so
here's maxine waters uh just a quick
montage of her calling
for violence the people are going to
turn on them
they're going to protest they're going
to absolutely harass them
until they decide that they're going to
tell the president
no i can't hang with you i will go and
take trump out tonight
to cheesecake factory
no sleep you see anybody from that
cabinet
in a restaurant in a department store
at a gasoline station you get out and
you create a crowd
and you push back on them they're not
welcome and just to be clear lest i be
removed from youtube here
i don't want i'm not calling anyone to
violence i don't want anyone to hurt her
but could you just take off her weave
and throw it into oncoming traffic
just the weave just the embarrassed just
just a little bit of embarrassment
oh look out guys it's a tumble weave
eight car pileup
they're avoiding it because they think
it's tire rubber
it's alive now so that was pretty clear
right form a mob
i mean would you would we all agree that
i'm not we're not playing gotcha no
yeah that's pretty pretty active one if
especially after what happened with the
trump thing
yeah absolutely and i want to show that
clip for contrast at no point did she
even specify peacefully by the way she
would not ever wait to see more
confrontational stay in the streets so
she's not even talking about a permit
right or an area where you have the
right to be let's compare maxine waters
with
the kind of rhetoric and by the way you
can buy your fight like hell [ __ ] at
crowdershop.com
that's why we're selling it because
every member of congress the senate has
used that at some point i don't know if
you know
just a month we could just run for two
hours because people say fight like hell
all the time but apparently maxine
waters gets a pass let's compare it with
people who had the right to be there
this was planned a permit
and donald trump addressing them and
keep in mind too when donald trump
addressed them there had never been
any kind of violent action uh on behalf
of right wingers you can think of the
tea partiers you can think of the people
who went out there to protest
uh lockdowns even the state capital they
had big scary rifles in michigan
they weren't shooting anybody you may
not like it
but very very different from the kinds
of riots that we've seen so let's
compare maxine waters to what got donald
trump
tried and removed from all
of the digital town square and we fight
we fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell
you're not going to have a country
anymore we will never give up we will
never concede it doesn't happen you
don't concede when there's
theft involved i know that everyone here
will soon be marching over to the
capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
so again let's keep this in context and
by the way you could show those clips
out of context and it's enough yeah but
i don't want to do what the prosecuting
attorney is doing i want to actually
give you the full story and provide some
context in
context at that point there were uh a
lot of people upset about the way that
the election went
and i'm not talking about i'm not even
talking about massive voter fraud we're
not even talking about that we're
talking about changes to the rules
yeah right we're talking about uh
anomalies we're talking about mail and
voting and people believing that there
should be id laws people who were upset
uh and donald trump was speaking to a
crowd where there was no plan
for violence that we knew of uh and
there had been no violent acts before
that you're talking about a crowd of
several hundred thousand people and
you're talking about maybe 20 who ended
up committing an act of violence
compared with maxine waters who
after there have already been dozens of
deaths
after there have already been hundreds
of officer casualties after
cities have been burning non-stop and
they would have the opportunity people
like maxine waters people like
kamala harris would have the chance to
come out and say you know what hey
there's a right way to do this
peacefully not only that not only did
she encourage it all
along the way she showed up in minnesota
to say that unless there is a guilty
verdict no no
not manslaughter we need to be in the
streets you need to stay in the streets
and be more confrontational
not only is that in my opinion illegal
and an active call to violence
but oh my god could you give any worse
advice for children
could you give any worse advice for
teenagers for young adults who don't
want to be caught in crossfire for
crying out loud and let's just also keep
this in context
2021 110 white people have been killed
by
uh police officers 53 black people and
everything to say but they make up 12
of the population but they make up the
significant majority of violent crimes
in this country well and police
interactions is the baseline there
you're not looking at the population
population any usable information at all
but none of it matters if you started
off with racism well there are more
police interactions
with black people because all cops are
racist what about the black cops well
they're uncle toms that would just what
about the fact that there are more
violent crimes being committed what
about the fact that black americans
speed more
these are these are statistical
realities and so they're going to be
more interactions and still
significantly less
shot by police officers what's what's
really pissed me off i think that wapo
article actually made the point you can
actually go down there and search by
year
by race by gender there's all these
different things and it'll show you how
many people there were
last year two or three hundred more
white people shot by police yeah but
then in that same article
they said that it's you're much more
likely to be shot by the police if
you're black
and that's the narrative that's going
around that maxine waters and everybody
is trumpeting and that's just
not true if you interact with the police
the most likely thing that's going to
happen is going to be determined on your
behavior not
based on your skin color not based on
anything other than how you act
and nobody is saying this in every one
of these cases that we've seen in the
media recently
if you don't attack the police if you
don't violently resist arrest
you will 99.9999 times
go to jail right alive by the way you
don't have people don't understand this
you don't have the right to resist
arrest no you have the right to
deny search right well no you can't
search my car you should know your
rights you have the right to deny entry
if someone wants to come into your house
without a warrant
yeah they can get a warrant but you have
the right to deny this you have the
right to an attorney you have the right
to not speak with them at all if they
take you in for interrogation
you do not have the right if a police
officer at that point you're under
suspicion is arresting you you don't
have the right to resist arrest your
rights exist
before that and then you're right your
rights exist after that
in the process let's just be really
clear about that some people say well
you know it's
my rights your right is not to resist
arrest at that point if there's
reasonable suspicion
they have the right to take you to uh to
uh well
i want to say i was gonna say downtown
but yeah not jail but they have the
right to take you to the police office
police headquarters
police station thanks and keep i've
never used a gentleman like downtown
paddy wagon
my james cagney police terminology yeah
it's uh turning it into boxing
up there yeah it would be the most
useful piece of advice that you can give
to kids right now it's just when when
you interact with a police officer just
understand their life is on the line
every single time and if
they are violating your rights yeah if
they're the time to fight that unless
you think they're killing you right then
right and then you obviously have to do
something
but if they're violating your rights sue
them right if they're doing something
and being disrespectful and illegally
searching your car even after you told
them you're not supposed to then try to
push them out of your car
sue them later you'll win yeah well this
is also and by the way comment you guys
watching if you're watching right now
live you know what if you can just hit
that like button because that also helps
you just right now everybody
click hit like right now do it live and
then you comment to me
let me know we're going to take your
chat here at mug club but let me know
what lesson you've taken from this what
advice would you give to someone based
on
not just this trial but right now the
environment in our country
the uh the black lives matter riots the
protests the counter protests
look this is right now the advice being
given to kids okay and you saw it was
being black in america was trending
yesterday it's
driving while black so the lesson from
maxine waters is we have got to
we have got to teach our cops to stop
being racist so look
that takes it out of your hands right
now we i know that we have a lot of uh
black viewers particularly young black
viewers
who are watching and right now what do i
do i can't fight the sit i can't fight
it's a racist system now there's nothing
you can do but the advice is
don't be black in america you know what
i would say this we'll leave on this
i would say that looking at this trial
gives us a lot
that we can take there's there's a lot
that you can use to deliver advice to
kids whether you're white or black and i
would say this no one's saying this
but if i were maxine waters if i were
joe biden if i were kamala harris
i'm me so i would say okay look
if you have a drug problem get help okay
first off if you have those resources
are available if you have a drug problem
get help before that
let's avoid doing drugs particularly
hard drugs okay let's try and avoid that
surround yourself with people who aren't
doing hard drugs so kids out there
that's very important the power of
association you see it with mama which
is who he thought was his mother but his
girlfriend this is not someone who's
going to pull him out of doing drugs
this is someone who encouraged him to
live that life likely caused him
to relapse okay so kids these are things
that you can do with your life
right stay in school sure uh
things that are out of your control
ideally you have a strong relationship
with your parents
stay in school but let's not do drugs
let's avoid gangs
let's avoid committing even petty petty
crimes because they lead to more serious
crimes
now if you find yourself in a situation
let's not
let's not uh abuse fellow members of
your community by screwing them out of
their hard-earned dollar
in uh giving out counterfeit bills okay
let's when a cop pulls you over and says
see your hands look
it's good for you to comply and show
your hands let's just go with blanket
rules like the rules that my dad taught
me
hands at ten and two roll down the
window and let the
hello officer if you have a concealed
carry permit hand it to them when they
request
your license along with your proper
identification if the police officer
asks you to get out of the car
get out of the car if at that point
you notice that you have drugs don't try
and swallow them
don't try and swallow them also don't
lie to the cops and say that you haven't
done anything wrong
that you haven't taken any drugs these
are all steps that you can if you want
to avoid this situation
then don't actively resist arrest and
avoid
and refuse to be put in the cop car
because we see what happens in that that
scenario
also don't kick cops
if you avoid all of these things you
might be better off so again the general
the general rules the advice that we
should be giving is white black doesn't
matter it's not about driving while
black
let's not drive while high let's have
better friends
better association let's make sure that
you have people around you in your life
who help
elevate you let's not actively resist
arrest and put police officers in
scenarios where they have to fear for
their lives
let's not lie to cops try and hide drugs
and then actively violently kick them
and you know what you end up with
scenarios like
hey hey this this that could have just
been me no you know what that couldn't
have just as easily been you
but you know who can be you ben carson
ben carson give me condoleezza rice cola
these are people who came from really
joe frazier muhammad ali
lebron take your pick there are lots of
people who've been in similar scenarios
who have had choices to make and instead
we are not
giving this advice to anyone we're
saying
it's being black in america that's not
what it is
and that remo that makes people feel
powerless and then they riot because
well there's nothing i can do
the problem is being black in america
well obviously he didn't watch the tape
because the two people who were in the
car they were also black in america
and nothing ever happened they were
entirely compliant the cops let them go
on their merry way with their
lululemon handbag or as brian stelter
says oh i maybe want that can i turn
that into a purse
all right we're going to go uh to mug
club continue watching this and we'll
take your chat thank you so much we
haven't changed my mind tomorrow
if you're on youtube hit like comment